COMMITTEE FOR WEDNESDAY JUNE
THIRD TWENTY TWENTY IS HEREBY
CALLED ORDER. REVISE ON AUDIO
AND VIDEO RECORDING OF TODAY'S
PROCEDURES BEING MADE AND IS
ALSO BEING TELEVISED. ADAM
SCHEFTER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM. HERE
YEAH YEAH. RIO FLORA YOUR
RESPONSE THERE. YEAH YOUR- YEAH
YOUR LONG THERE. YEAH WE HAVE
WE'RE LOOKING YOU'RE GOING. WE
HAVE A QUORUM. YEAH. DO THE
CURRENT STAY HOME ORDER WE ARE
PRESSING PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL BUILDING
SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER PEOPLE WATCH AND
PARTICIPATE THE HEARING IN
PERSON. WE HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY
TODAY. FOR THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM HERE AND FORTY TWO TWO. WE
ARE HAVING A PHYSICALLY DISTANT
IN PERSON HEARING. IN THIS
SPACE WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE
ELEVEN MEMBERS A MINIMAL
CONDITIONS STAFF AND A LIMITED
NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC AND MEDIA%
SO WE CAN MAINTAIN SIX FEET OF
SPACING. THEY'RE ALSO STRICT
PHYSICAL DSTANCE IN PROTOCOLS
FOR THE PUBLIC TO ENTER AND
LEAVE THE CAPITAL AND FOR THOSE
HERE TODAY IN THE HEARING. I
HAVE A- TO BUY CONSTITUENTS
HUSBAND WIFE WERE CITY
TOGETHER. AND SO THEY ARE OF
DOING THAT THE- HUSBAND WIFE SO
WELCOME HERE. THEY'RE ALSO
STRUCK FISCAL PHYSICAL
DISAPPROVAL CALLS FOR THE
PUBLIC. IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY WE WILL ASK YOU TO
RAISE YOUR HANDS TO DO COURSE.
AND AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME ALL
I SHOULD POST A MICROPHONE. AND
INDICATE THE MICROPHONE
QUESTION. WE ASK THE PUBLIC NOT
TO TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. THAT
IS FOR YOUR WELL BEING AND
THOSE TO. THE WELL BEING OF
THOSE THAT FOLLOW YOU. ARE YOU
CONNECTED TO HER ONCE YOU ARE
DONE TESTIFYING TO RETURN YOUR
SEATS. BEING INSURED TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DOESN'T STAND UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITOL. INCLUDING
LIVE AN ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. OF FOR OUR
DIAL IN WITNESSES FOR WHOM WE
HAVE. A NUMBER ALREADY PLANNED
WE'LL USE A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE TO WHICH ANY WITNESS
CAN TESTIFY ON ASSEMBLY COUNTRY
FROM A TWENTY FIVE. THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS AREA
CODE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
AGAIN THAT'S. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. AND THERE IS AN ACCESS
CODE. THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE
THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR TWO OH
TWO. AGAIN. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR TWO OH TWO IS THE ACCESS
CODE. YOU'LL FIND THAT NUMBER
ON THE ASSEMBLY RULES COMMITTEE
WEBSITE WHICH IS ACCESSIBLE
FROM THE MAIN ASSEMBLY WEBSITE
ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOV. AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREENS. IF
YOUR CALL IN AND PLEASE PLAN TO
DO SO AS THE AUTHOR BEGINS
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION. THE
OPERATE ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED THE QUEUE. BASED ON WHAT
YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE BILL
THEY'LL PUT YOU IN A PROPER Q.
WE DO ASK IF YOUR CALL IN AND
TO ELIMINATE BACKGROUND NOISE.
THIS INCLUDES MUTINEER
LIFESCRIPT STREAM BROADCAST.
AND YOUR SMART DEVICES TO
REDUCE THE SOUND DISTORTION.
PLEASE BE ADVISED ALSO PROVIDES
OF YOUR MAIN WITNESS. PROVIDE
TEST ONE FOR INSTABILITY YOUR
MAN ON LIVE LINE AND YOU WILL
NEED TO MOVE YOURSELF UNTIL YOU
WERE CALLED ON TO SPEAK. IF
ANYONE HAS PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATE PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL THE RULES COMMITTEE. AT.
NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE TWO
EIGHT ZERO ZERO. AGAIN NINE ONE
SIX THREE ONE NINE TWO EIGHT
ZERO ZERO. AND THE RULES
COMMITTEE STAFF WILL BE THERE
TO ASSIST. I ALSO WANT TO NOTE
THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO THE- POSITION OUR
PORTAL ON THE RULES COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AND AGAIN THAT IS
ACCESSIBLE TO THE COMMITTEE
LINK AND ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT
GOV. AND I THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEARING WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT
MATHIS TO CONTINUE SERVE THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. WHILE
BEING MINDFUL RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE. WE HAVE THREE ITEMS ON
OUR AGENDA TODAY. ITEM ONE IS
ON CONSENT AND I WANT TO START
WITH ITEM ONE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. DO IT IN ONE WISH TO
SPEAK TO THE CONSENT CALIBER
FOR TAKEN UP. NUMBER RAMOS WHO
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND I LIKE THE POOL- ACA
SIXTEEN FROM THE CONSENT.
CALENDAR FOR FURTHER
DISCUSSION. OKAY SUCH WILL BE
THE ORDER. ITEM. ACA SIXTEEN IS
REMOVED FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS OUR MOTION ON THE
REMAINDER OF THE CONSENT
CALENDAR MISTER CHAIR IF I
COULD I'D LIKE TO ROOM
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST WE REMOVE
ITEM THREE- SB FOUR TWENTY
THREE. FROM CONSENT AS WELL.
OKAY. CAN WE DO THAT IS. BETTER
SECRETARY. AND SO IT'S JUS A
REGULAR RIGHT. NEVER MIND RIGHT
AND I WAS NOT CLEAR ON THAT SO
THAT'S ON ME. WOULD YOU MOVE
THE CLASSIC OUR- I'D LIKE TO
MOVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR IT IS
OUR SECOND SECONDED BY MS QUIRK
SILVA LETTER SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR I'M COOLEY AYE COOLEY
AYE CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I.
CARILLO FLORA. FLOOR ARE
GRAYSON. GRAYSON I'D-
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS BY MATHIS
AYE QUIRK SILVA QUIRK SILVA I
RAMOS FROM US I RIVAS.
RIVERSIDE WORKS LEVINE LEVINE
AYE MOTION PASSES. OKAY AND-
JUST APPROPRIATE MOMENT TO
ADDRESS ITEM A CA SIXTEEN. OKAY
ARM. CAN I GET A MOTION ON THAT
AND A SECOND AND THEN WE WILL.
OPEN UP FOR DISCUSSION. MISTER
CHAIR COULD WE SPEAK TO THE
ITEM FIRST DOORS ARE YOU
LOOKING FOR A MOTION PRIOR. I
WAS LOOKING FOR A MOTION PRIOR.
BUT IF YOU WANT IT WAS TO SPEAK
TO IT MISTER CHARLES I CAN'T
MISTER ALMOST AS AN TO OPEN IT
UP FOR THIS. OKAY OKAY MISTER
AT ALL RIGHT TO GO INTO YES
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF I DID PULL ACA
SIXTEEN I THINK. YOU KNOW WITH
THE THINGS THAT HAVE HAPPENED-
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE THE
COVE IT AND THEN WE SEE A LOT
OF THE PROTESTS GOING ON. THIS
CERTAINLY WE ARE. LOOKING AT
BILLS THAT ARE MOVING THROUGH
THE PROCESS AND BEING REFERRED-
HOWEVER THIS IS A BILL THAT I
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
FULLY UNDERSTAND THAT. THE
IMPACTS THAT IT HAS HAS ON
TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTYHAS ON ON
STATE COMPACTS. HAS ON
DISCUSSION MOVING FORWARD. WE
SEE A CA SIXTEEN AND IS CURRENT
FORM WE KNOW IT'S GOING TO BE
MORE TOWARDS THE END SO THIS IS
A BILL THAT THAT REALLY HAS
SERIOUS- A FAX HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE TRULY
WARRANT SOME MORE DISCUSSION-
TO MOVE FORWARD HOWEVER
UNDERSTANDING. THE PROCESS AND
WE'RE IN NOW. THE THAT
DISCUSSION DOES NEED TO MOVE
FORWARD- SO THAT ALL VOICES ARE
BEING HEARD. THOSE THAT ARE
RAISING OPPOSITION TO THIS. BUT
I THINK WE'RE SITTING HERE
TODAY AND BRINGING ATTENTION TO
IT BECAUSE OF THE IMPACT THAT
IT HAS IN THE SPEEDING THIS
THAT WHICH IT SHOWED UP IN IS
MOVING FORWARD. SO I WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT MY COLLEAGUES
TRULY UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS
COMPONENTS DEALING WITH TRIBAL
SOVEREIGNTY THERE'S COMPONENTS
DEALING WITH A STATE COMPACT
THERE'S COMPONENTS DEALING WITH
THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND I WOULD ASK- I
KNOW THE AUTHOR TO BE ABLE TO
ENGAGE THAT DISCUSSION- MOVING
FOR WITH ALL THOSE THAT WE
JUST- ALLUDED TO. BECAUSE BY NO
MEANS. SUPPORTING THIS BILL
MOVING FORWARD TODAY DOES BY NO
MEANS MEAN THAT I WILL BE IN
SUPPORT OF IT ON THE FLOOR
UNLESS THESE TYPES OF
DISCUSSIONS START TO TAKE PLACE
AND HAS MEANING FULL MUTUAL
RESPECTFUL. DIALOG HAPPENING.
THAT'S WHY I PULLED A CA
SIXTEEN- MISTER CHAIR BECAUSE
OF THE COMPONENTS THAT ARE
INVOLVED IN IT THAT I WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT MY COLLEAGUES
TRULY UNDERSTOOD THE IMPACT
THAT IT HAS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR GOOD. ON THE MS QUIRK
SILVA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. I
WANTED TO SPEAK TO- ACA SIXTEEN
JUST IN GENERAL BUT IN THE
PROCESS OF MOVING THE BILL
FORWARD. IN BILLS BEING HEARD
AND NOT FOR ONE OF THE THINGS
OVER THE LAST HANDFUL YOU OF
YEARS- AND AGAIN- IN RULES WE
MOVED BILLS INTO. THE
DESIGNATED COMMITTEE THAT THE
CHAIR HAS DECIDED WOULD BE THE
APPROPRIATE PLACE SOMETIMES TO
COMMITTEES. BUT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE DON'T TALK
ABOUT- IS ONE BILLS ARE NOT
HEARD AT ALL BY THE CHAIR. AND
I JUST WANTED TO GO ON RECORD
AS I HAVE WITH A COLLEAGUE-
FROM THE REPUBLICAN SIDE JOE
JAY OBERNOLTE WHERE WE WROTE
ABOUT. WE FEEL THAT IF WE ARE
ELECTED. AS A WHOLE THAT ARE
BILL SHOULD BE HEARD WHETHER BE
BY DEMOCRAT OR REPUBLICAN
BECAUSE- WHEN WE DON'T HEAR
BILLS AND A CHAIR IS ABLE I
KNOW THAT'S BEEN PART OF THE
SPEAKERS- LEADERSHIP. BUT WE'RE
ALL ELECTED IN OUR DISTRICTS
AND WHEN IT CHAIR HAS
OPPORTUNITY JUST TO SAY THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO HEAR BEAR THEIR OF
CERTAIN BILLS OR SOME BILLS. IT
REALLY DIMINISHES THE ROLE WE
CAN PLAY SO I JUST WANT TO-
EXPRESS THAT PUBLICLY THAT WE
SHOULD BE HEARING BILLS THAT
MEMBERS BRING FORWARD. AND HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO OF THAT AND
TO HAVE CRITICAL DISCUSSIONS
HOUSE MISTER RAMOS IS SAID
BECAUSE WE ARE MAKING
DECISIONS. ON MAJOR ISSUES THAT
AFFECT MANY ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. FOR THAT
MR LIVING. I WANT TO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN ECHO-
THE CONCERNS AND COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES I'M REALLY GRATEFUL.
TO THEM FOR RAISING THOSE
ISSUES I DON'T WANT TO SPEAK.
SUBSTANTIVELY TO THE BILL-
THOUGH I'D HAVE GRAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT ABOUT IT- I THINK THAT
THAT SHOULD BE HEARD. IN POLICY
COMMITTEE I'M HOPEFUL THAT IN
POLICY COMMITTEE IS GIVEN A
FULL. VETTING AND FULLY TALK
THROUGH THE POSITIVES AND
NEGATIVES OF IT. THIS IS THE
COMMITTEE FOR THAT. THIS IS THE
COMMITTEE WHERE- WE ALLOW IT TO
GET HEARD AND- IN AGAIN TO
ECHO- THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES. I BELIEVE THAT THE
CURRENT STRUCTURE WE HAVE OF
ALLOWING CHAIRS TO NOT HEAR A
BILL- SHOWS EIGHTY EIGHTY
CURRENT MORAL BANKRUPTCY ABOUT
THE REPRESENTATIVE GOVERNMENT
THAT WE HAVE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. IT IS WRONG AND-
AND THAT IS THE ONLY REASON WHY
I'M GOING TO VOTE HI TO ALLOW
THIS BILL TO BE HEARD. THANK
YOU. IS THERE A MOTION TO REFER
THIS ACA SIXTEEN TO THE GEO
COMMITTEE. SOME OF MOVED.
ASYLUM MEMBERS RAMOS TO REVERSE
SECOND ROOM IS CARILLO MATTER
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY HI. COOLEY I AND I'M
SURE THIS IS ON THE REFERRAL OF
ACA SIXTEEN TO GEO AND
APPROPRIATIONS- COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I.
CARILLO. CORREO AYE FLORA FLORA
AYE GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MATHIS AYE
AYE QUIRK SILVA AND QUIRK SILVA
I RAMOS I. ALMOST I RIVAS RIVAS
AYE LEVINE LEVINE I THOUGHT
MOTION PASSAGE. VERY GOOD-
ISSUE SIXTEEN IS REFER TO THE
GEO COMMITTEE AND- WE'LL NOW GO
TO HIGHLAND TO ON A REGULAR
AGENDA A SHEET TWENTY FIVE BY
SELLING MEMBER MOLEN- SUMMER
MORE WOULD YOU LIKE 2% ON THIS
MEASURE. THANK YOU WENDY. I'M
VERY SORRY FOR. THIS MORNING MY
OPEN ON THE MEASURE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PLEASED TO
PRESENT TO YOU A TRULY
BIPARTISAN BILL THAT IS LONG
OVERDUE. I HAVE DISTRIBUTED
AMENDMENTS THAT SHOULD ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS OF THE OPPOSITION
WE HAVE DELETED THE ENTIRE
SECTION THAT ALLOWS FOR ANY
WAIVER OF PROVISIONS OF
PROPOSITION FIFTY FOUR. IN
ADDITION I'M ADDING LIKE WHICH
INDICATE THAT REMOTE VOTING
SHALL ONLY APPLY WHEN MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATURE ARE
PREVENTED FROM SAFELY ATTENDING
IN PERSON. HERE IN THIS
BUILDING WITH THAT I BELIEVE WE
HAVE ADDRESSED CONCERNS WHICH
CAME TO OUR ATTENTION IN THE
LAST FORTY EIGHT HOURS.
CALIFORNIA AS YOU ALL KNOW IS
THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD WITH A POPULATION OF
FORTY MILLION WE HAVE A FULL
TIME LEGISLATURE WHICH UNDER
NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES. IS ABLE
TO FAIRLY NIMBLY A RESPOND BY
PASSING URGENCY LEGISLATION AND
IT JUST SPENDING PRIORITIES IN
REAL TIME. WHEN CONDITIONS
WARRANT. HOWEVER IT TOOK EIGHT
WORLDWIDE PANDEMIC PRESS TO
DISCOVER THAT CALIFORNIA'S
GOVERNMENT IS UNPREPARED TO
CONTINUE TO FUNCTION DURING
SUCH A WIDESPREAD DISRUPTIVE
EMERGENCY. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS NO CURRENT
AUTHORITY TO ALLOW FOR THE
CONTINUITY OF GOVERNMENT. THAT
IS FOR THE LEGISLATIVE BRANCH
OF GOVERNMENT TO CONVENE DURING
AN EMERGENCY IT DECLARED
EMERGENCY BY THE GOVERNOR OR
THE PRESIDENT WHERE AND IT
WOULD BE UNSAFE FOR MEMBERS TO
GATHER AND MEET IN PERSON. ACA
TWENTY FIVE SIX TO PUT BEFORE
THE VOTERS A CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT. THAT WOULD REQUIRE
BOTH HOUSES OF THIS LEGISLATURE
TO ADOPT RULES WHICH WOULD
ALLOW FOR THE SWORN DUTIES OF
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONTINUE AND
TO REQUIRE SUCH RULES TO
PROVIDE FOR AND MAINTAIN
MAXIMUM TRANSPARENCY AND ACCESS
BY THE PUBLIC. WHILE
MAINTAINING THE INTEGRITY OF
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. THE
IMPACT OF COVERT NINETEEN HAS
SHOWN US THAT THERE ARE A WIDE
RANGE OF MODERN TECHNOLOGIES
AVAILABLE TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
TO ACCESS COMMITTEE HEARINGS
AND FLOOR SESSION AND I BELIEVE
THESE TECHNOLOGIES WILL BECOME
EVEN MORE ACCESSIBLE MOVING
FORWARD ACA TWENTY FIVE
PRESERVES THE PUBLIC'S RIGHT TO
A COURT CHALLENGE IF THEY FEEL
YOUR LATER ACTED CONSISTENT.
WITH THE TERMS OF THE AMENDMENT.
IN TWO STATES OR AGAIN AND
WISCONSIN SPECIFIC CONTINUITY
OF GOVERNMENT PROVISIONS ALLOW
FOR THE REMOTE MEETING OF THE
LEGISLATURE. FROM MARCH THROUGH
MAY TWENTY TWENTY
LEGISLATURE'S- CHAMBERS AND AT
LEAST TWENTY STATES RED AND
BLUE STATES. CHANGE THEIR
PROCEDURES TO ALLOW FOR REMOTE
PARTICIPATION OR VOTING AND
FLOOR SESSION. OR COMMITTEE
MEETINGS. CALIFORNIA IS SEEKING
TO DO THIS THE RIGHT WAY BY
ASKING ARE VOTERS TO APPROVE A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT. TO
ALLOW WHAT TWENTY STATES ARE
ALREADY DOING BY DECREE. THE
LEGISLATURE IS A CO EQUAL
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT BUT
BETWEEN OUR DEPARTURE FROM THE
CAPITAL TO AN EARLY KOBE DRIVEN
SPRING RECESS AND ARE RETURNED
EARLIER THIS MONTH. THE
GOVERNOR ISSUED THIRTY
EXECUTIVE ORDERS MOST OF WHICH
I AGREE WITH AND I APPLAUD THE
GOVERNOR FOR. A DESPITE SOME OF
THE VERY LATE NOTICE- IN SOME
CIRCUMSTANCES. BUT NONE THE
LESS THE LEGISLATURE MUST
CONTINUE ITS OVERSIGHT
FUNCTIONS AND MAINTAIN CHECKS
AND BALANCES EVEN IN THE TIME
OF AN EMERGENCY. GOVERNMENT BY
EXECUTIVE FIAT IS NOT WHAT THE
FOUNDING FATHERS HAD IN MIND
WHEN ESTABLISHING THREE
SEPARATE CO EQUAL BRANCHES OF
GOVERNMENT. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. VERY GOOD THANK YOU
MISTER MALONE WILL NOW GO TO
WITNESSES AND WE HAVE NO KEY
WITNESSES LISTEN SUPPORT. ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES TO SUPPORT
IN THE HEARING ROOM. SEEING
NONE OF THE FIRST WANT TO
INVITE THE MODERATOR TO PLEASE
OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR ANYONE
IN SUPPORT OF ACA TWENTY FIVE.
AND ARE YOU WITH US MODERATOR.
I AM AT YOUR AND THE POOREST
ONE ZERO AT THAT TIME. WELL
THAT ISUNFOLDING- DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OUR
MODERATOR. WE'VE GOT ADELINE
EIGHT UP MY MOM AND. THE. RIGHT
BOTTOM LINE EIGHT CALLAHAN.
GOOD AFTERNOON PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF AND- PROVIDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF A CA
TWENTY FIVE. LINE SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
STEVE EDGAR AND I THINK IT'S A
GREAT IDEA AND I SUPPORT THIS.
BUILT THANK YOU MISTER EDGAR.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MAXWELL BUT A LINE EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IF. AT EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT CONNECTED. THERE'S
NO ONE OUT TO MAKE YOU NO ONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM MODERATOR- WILL
TURN OUT TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OUR FIRST WITNESS
WILL BE DOMINIC TOMARI- MR
TOMORROW THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US. HERE IN THIS CHAMBERS THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS DOMINIC TOMORROW AND
I'M HERE IN MY CAPACITY AS
PRESIDENT. OF THE INSTITUTE OF
GOVERNMENTAL ADVOCATES OR AYE
JAYE HERE IN SACRAMENTO
REPRESENTING. LOBBYISTS AND
ADVOCATES IN TOWN. BEFORE YOU
THE LEGISLATURE AND IN GENERAL-
WE ARE OPPOSED TO A SU TWENTY
FIVE. AND WE THANK THE AUTHOR
AND THIS COMMITTEE FOR THE
AMENDMENTS THAT REMOVE SOME OF
THE MORE OBJECTIONABLE PARTS.
RELATIVE TO TELEVISING PUBLIC
ACCESS HOWEVER I THINK THAT WE
HAVE A FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCE.
IN TERMS OF HOW E VIEW THE
ROLE OF THIS INSTITUTION AND
WHERE IT SHOULD BE DOING ITS
BUSINESS. I WILL SPEAK FIRST AS
AN ADVOCATE AND ON BEHALF OF MY
COLLEAGUES WE'VE HAD A VERY
DIFFICULT TIME FOR FILLING OUR
OBLIGATIONS TO THE- TO THE
CLIENTS IN THE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT WE REPRESENT. UNDER THE
PANDEMIC AND SO WE DON'T TAKE
ISSUE WITH THE DECISIONS THAT
WERE MADE WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE IS A BALANCE THAT NEEDS
TO BE REACHED BETWEEN
PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY. AND CONDUCTING THE
BUSINESS OF THE STATE. BUT THE
FUNDAMENTAL ELEMENTS OF THE
STATE AND OF THIS INSTITUTION.
STATE YOUR IS ACT TO THE- TO BE
ABLE TO DO YOUR PROCEEDINGS IN
YOUR DOUBLE THE DELIBERATIONS.
IN THE OPENING DAY LIFE IN THE
TRANSPARENCY. NATURE OF THE
PROCEEDINGS IS WHAT MAKES THE
DEMOCRACY WORK. AND TOO WHEN
YOU. AND YOU REMOVE YOURSELF
FROM THE ABILITY OF THE PUBLIC
TO BEAR WITNESS TO WHAT YOU'RE
DOING. IT MAKES IT VERY
DIFFICULT FOR THE PUBLIC TO
HAVE THE CONTINUED CONFIDENCE
IN THE RESULTS THAT YOU
PRODUCED HERE. AND SO FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE WE FEEL THAT THIS
IS A VERY SLIPPERY SLOPE TO BE
GOING DOWN. AGAIN RECOGNIZING
THE NEED TO BALANCE PUBLIC
SAFETY AND PERSONAL SAFETY
AGAINST THE RESPONSIBILITIES OF
THE LEGISLATURE. AND SPEAKING
AS A CITIZEN OF CALIFORNIA I
SHARE THE SAME VIEWS AND I
THINK MY COLLEAGUES DO AS WELL.
AND FOR US THE LEGISLATURE IS
THESE A SYMBOL OF THE
GOVERNMENT. YOU HAVE THE
EXECUTIVE AND MISTER MULLIN
SPOKE VERY WELL OF. THE
EXECUTIVE POWER AND THE USE OF
THAT EXECUTIVE POWER OVER THESE
LAST FEW MONTHS. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN SOMEWHAT
IN ADVANCE YOUR BACK AND THAT'S
A GREAT THING FROM THE BALANCE
OF POWER POINT OF VIEW. BUT THE
ISSUE IS THIS BUILDING THIS-CAPITAL REPRESENTS THE
LEGISLATURE IN GOVERNMENT. AND
IN TIMES OF CRISIS LIKE WE ARE
NOW THE PANDEMIC NO ONE COULD
HAVE FORESEEN THAT. THE CIVIL
UNREST AND WE SEE VERY IN THE
STREETS AROUND OUR STATE AND
AROUND THE COUNTRY. THIS
MOMENT. NO WHATEVER COULD HAVE
PREDICTED A PANDEMIC. AND THE
CIVIL UNREST THAT WE'RE SEEING
TODAY THE CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIANS LOOK TO YOU. IN
THIS ROOM IN THIS BUILDING FOR
LEADERSHIP THIS BUILDING IS THE
SYMBOL OF THAT LEADERSHIP. AND
WHEN YOU LEAVE YOU NEED TO
LEAVE FROM HERE. THIS IS WHERE
YOU BELONG. AND SO FOR OUR
POINT OF VIEW AS PROFESSIONALS
YES WE'VE ENTERED A VERY
DIFFICULT TIME. WE WILL WISH TO
HAVE A DIALOGUE ABOUT HOW WE
CAN MAKE IT BETTER IN THE
FUTURE. FROM THE LARGER POINT
OF VIEW OF GOVERNANCE AND THE
RESPONSIBILITY THAT WE ALL HAVE
TO OUR DEMOCRACY. THIS IS A BAD
IDEA AND THAT THE MINUTE WE
START REMOVING OURSELVES TO OUR
LIBRARIES IN GOVERNING OVER
ASSUME CALL. THAT THAT'S A BAD
TURN FOR US SO. I WOULD ASK
THAT THIS. BODY THIS COMMITTEE.
VOTE NO ON THIS MEASURE LET'S
GO BACK LET'S FIGURE OUT A WAY
THAT ISN'T AS BROAD AND I WILL
END WITH THIS ON A TECHNICAL
NOTE. IN HERE AND I APPRECIATE
AGAIN THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
MADE BUT I KNOW THAT THE REMOTE
METHODS AUTHORIZED PURSUANT TO
THIS SECTION SHALL ONLY BE
UTILIZED WHEN A STATE OF
EMERGENCY PREVENTS. ANY MEMBER
OF THE LEGISLATURE FROM SAFELY
ATTENDING A LEGISLATIVE
PROCEEDING A PERSON DOES THAT
MEAN THAT IF ONE OF YOU IN THIS
ROOM ARE PREVENTED FROM.
ATTENDING THIS PROCEEDING A
PERSON THAT THE ENTIRE
PROCEEDINGS CANCELED OR THAT
THE ENTIRE LEGISLATURE WILL BE
ABLE TO VOTE AND LEGISLATE
REMOTELY. WE NEED MORE. TIME TO
DISCUSS AND WORK OUT THE
DETAILS AROUND HOW THIS CAN BE
DONE. BUT NO THIS FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE. WE REALLY DO
BELIEVE THIS IS A SLIPPERY
SLOPE. THAT WE SHOULDN'T BE
TAKING BECAUSE- THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF YOU FOLKS
HERE AS ELECTED OFFICIALS IS TO
BE HERE. AND TO LEGISLATE SO
WITH THAT I HUMBLY AND
RESPECTFULLY SUBMIT OUR
OPPOSITION ON BEHALF OF I. GA
AND OTHERS AROUND TOWN THANK
YOU SO MUCH. MORE RESPECT FOR.
LET US TURN THIS TIME WHEN THEY
WITNESSES PHONE LINE THOSE
OPPOSITION- ABOUT A MODERATOR
WE HAVE GOT THE TROLLS NUMBER.
FOR RIGHT I AM HAVING A HARD
TIME HERE YOU DID YOU SAY YOU
WANTED TO GO TO THOSE IN
OPPOSITION HEARD ME I HAD THANK
YOU- YES GOOD THE OPPOSITION
DOCTOR CHARLES MUNGER OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HONORABLE
MEMBERS I'M PARTICIPATING BY
TELEPHONE INSIDE WE STAFF FOR
TWO POINTS OF CLARIFICATION. OF
THE HONORABLE MEMBER OF
SUBMITTED A SET OF THE NINE
MONTHS TO- ACA TWENTY FIVE I'M
ASKING ONE OF THOSE AMENDMENTS
ARE IDENTICAL TO THE ONE WHICH
I WAS- SENT BY- THE EIGHT.
THIRTY FOR STAFF. OF THE
COMMITTEE AND I ALSO WISH TO
ASK- IF THOSE AMENDMENTS HAVE
BEEN DULY ADOPTED OR BY THIS
COMMITTEE BEFORE I PROCEED TO
MY REMARKS AND BE HELPFUL NOT
TO ATTACK. SOMETHING WHICH IS
NO LONGER IN THE BILL. YEAH
DAYS. DR MARGARET THIS IS
ASSEMBLYMEMBERCOOLEY. SO THE
AMENDMENT STRIKE SECTION THREE
AND FOUR- AB AND C. ON PAGE
THREE. I HAVE THAT IN FRONT OF
ME AND INSERT THE LANGUAGE THAT
YOU SEE ADDED REMOTE METHODS
AUTHORIZED PURSUANT TO SECTION
SHALL ONLY BE UTILIZED. IN A
STATE OF EMERGENCY PREVENTS ANY
NUMBER OF MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE FROM SAFEETERNITY
LET'S SAY PROCEED IN PERSON-
ANY ACTION ON THIS BILL WILL BE
AND- TO ADOPTING THESE
AMENDMENTS- SO THAT IS THE BILL
BEFORE SIR. AS AMENDED. THANK
YOU SIR AND I'D LIKE TO BE I
MAY PLEASE CONTINUE AYE LETTER
YEAH PLEASE CONTINUE CERTAINLY.
I'M THINKING YOU MAKING TO YOU
TODAY AS ONE OF THE TWO
PROPONENTS OF- PROPOSITION
FIFTY FOUR WHICH ESTABLISHED
THE PROVISIONS IN THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION WHICH
THE- NOW REMOVED SECTIONS OF
EIGHTY EIGHT TWENTY FIVE WHAT
AFFECTED I HAD MANY OBJECTIONS
TO THOSE BUTTONS ARE NO LONGER
IN THE BILL I DON'T HAVE THOSE
OBJECTIONS- ON THE GENERAL
SUBJECT OF THIS BILL- TO
PREVIOUS SPEAKER HAS ALLUDED
TO. ON THE COMPLICATED ISSUES.
LACKEY VOTING IS APPROPRIATE
TIME WITH THE REMOTE VOTING AS
APPROPRIATE DELIVERY
COMPLICATED ISSUES BUT THEY'RE
NOT ISSUES ON WHICH I'D SAY-
THAT'S A PROPONENT OF THE
TRANSPARENCY MEASURE HAD ANY
PARTICULAR SAY PROVIDED INDEED
THAT. THE MEASURE THE CONDUCTED
WITH DUE REGARD TO BE COPIED
REQUIREMENTS FOR TRANSPARENCY
AND DON'T UNDERMINE THE- SO I
LOOK FORWARD TO PARTICIPATING
AS THIS BILL MOVES FOR THE
LEGISLATURE- TO. AVOID ANY
PROBLEMS I THANK THE HONORABLE
AUTHOR AND THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE FOR BEING VERY
RESPONSIVE TO. MY CONCERNS AND
THE CONCERNS OF THE WELL NIGH
TWO THIRDS OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO APPROVED
PROPOSITION FIFTY FOUR. AND I
THINK THAT- THE FACT THAT WE'RE
ON THE TELEPHONE CALL TODAY AND
THAT THIS WILL BECOME PART OF
THE PUBLIC RECORD IT'S HIGHLY
DESIRABLE. AND I LIKE YOU
WELCOME BEING HELD ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THE ARGUMENT I BRING HER
FAILED TO BRING THE
DELIBERATIONS ASSEMBLY. AND
WHAT THAT. I HAVE NO FURTHER
REMARKS TO MAKE ALTHOUGH I'M
HAPPY TO RESPOND TO ANY
QUESTIONS WHICH THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MAY WISH TO ASK
ABOUT HOW. BILL CONTINUES TO
FIGHT CONTINUE TO AFFECT
GOVERNMENT TRANSPARENCY OR
PROPOSITION FOR. THANK YOU
UNLESS YOU TO STAY ON THE LINE.
DR MUNGER AND OF COURSE YOUR
LETTER OF OPPOSITION IS A PART
OF THE- RECORD AS WELL SO THAT
CAME IN. PRIOR TO THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WILL BE
REFLECTED IN OUR RECORD. OF
THE- AND IF YOU'LL JUST KEEP
YOUR LINE OPEN WE WILL. TURN
OUT TO THE OTHER. OF MRS AND
THEN THERE MAY BE AFTER ALL MAY
INDEED HAVE QUESTIONS. IF
THAT'S AGREEABLE. SO MARILYN.
THAT'S AGREEABLE. ENTIRELY VERY
GOOD THEN LET'S OPEN THE LINE
OF MATTER MODERATOR FOR SENATOR
BLAKESLEE. YES THANK YOU BYE
CHAIR COOLEY A VICE CHAIR
CUNNINGHAM AND NUMBERS MY NAME
A SAMPLE EXPLAINED I PREVIOUSLY
SERVED IN THIS BODY AND HELD
ROLES SUCH A VICE CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE. AND MINORITY LEADER
LATER CERTAIN STATE SENATE SO
MY INTEREST IN HOW THIS A BODY
OPERATE VERY DEEPLY HELD A AND
IN FACT LEADING THE
LEGISLATURE. I'VE GONE ON TO
WORK ON GOVERNMENT TRANSPARENCY
AND SERVE AS FOUNDINGDIRECTOR
OF THE INSTITUTE FOR ADVANCED
TECHNOLOGY AND PUBLIC POLICY.
WHERE FACULTY ENOUGH WE GOT
PLATFORM BY NAME OF THE DIVIDE
BUT MANY VIEW MAY HAVE YOU. AT
PRIVILEGE OF WORKING DOCTOR
MUNGER AS CO AUTHOR AND CO
PROPONENT OF PROPOSITION FIFTY
FOUR WHICH IMPLEMENTED THE
SEVENTY TWO HOUR IMPRINT
REQUIREMENT. AND I CURRENTLY
SERVE AS THE VICE CHAIR. OF THE
BOARD ON THE BOARD OF COMMON
CAUSE CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE
AND I WILL NOTE. THAT EVERYONE.
WHO SERVED ON THE STATE SIDE
SIXTY FIVE COMMISSION. WHICH IS
GOOD TO GO. YEAH WELL AND I AM-
NOT A I AM A FORMER SCIENTIST
AND YOU KNOW I CARE VERY MUCH
ABOUT AND- ISSUES THAT PERTAIN
TO THE PUBLIC SAFETY SO THANK
YOU FOR MENTIONING THAT. I KNOW
THAT EVERYONE ON THIS COMMITTEE
YOUR BELIEFS AND THE THREE
FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLES OF OPEN
GOVERNMENT ONE THE PEOPLE'S
BUSINESS MUST BE CONDUCTED IN
PUBLIC CHOOSE THE PUBLIC HAS A
RIGHT TO PARTICIPATE IN
MEETINGS A THREE THE PUBLIC HAS
ACCESS PUBLIC DOCUMENTS. WHICH
FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLES WERE
ENACTED BY THE LEGISLATURE- AS
THEY APPLY TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
THROUGH THE BROWN ACT TO THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH TO BACK WE
CAME OPEN MEETINGS ACT. FOR ALL
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND EXECUTIVE
BRANCH DOCUMENTS TO THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC RECORDS ACT.
AND EVEN ON THE COURTS. THE SUN
SHINES OUT IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR.
WHICH DIRECTION THAT ALSO SAW
SHOULD BE QUOTE. BROADLY
CONSTRUED BURGERS WITH PEOPLE
WHO LIKE TO ACCESS AND NARROWLY
CONSTRUED IT LIMITS THE WHITE
OF ACCESS UNQUOTE. NOW ALL
THESE ACTS WERE WRITTEN BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN ALL EMPLOYMENT
OPEN GOVERNMENT PRINCIPLES ON
EVERY BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT
STATE ONE. AND COINCIDENTALLY
ENOUGH THE LEGISLATURE IS THE
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT- WHICH IS
EXEMPT FROM THESE- STATUTES AND
CONSTITUTIONAL NUMBERS WHICH I
MENTIONED. EE THE LEGISLATURE
HAS A HISTORY OF NOT DOING A
PARTICULARLY GOOD JOB WHEN IT
COMES TO LEGISLATING SUCH
MATTERS THAT GOVERN THE CONDUCT
OF THE BODY. THE LEGISLATIVE
OPEN RECORDS ACT IS NOW WIDELY
VIEWED AS THE OXY MORON. IN
ANOTHER EXAMPLE WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE WHAT THE SUNSHINE
ACT. IT ADDED A FINAL PARAGRAPH
BELIEVE THAT NIGHT THAT
EXEMPTED THE QUOTE PROCEEDINGS
AND RECORDS OF THE LEGISLATURE
UNQUOTE. NOW IS WORTH
CONSIDERING THE ADVERSE ALSO A
PUBLIC POLICY CONSEQUENCES OF
SUCH CARVE OUT BECAUSE THAT
FEEDBACK ALSO INCLUDED ANOTHER
EXEMPTION QUOTE. ON THE
DISCLOSURE OF INFORMATION
CONCERNING THE OFFICIAL
PERFORMANCE OF A PEACE OFFICER.
UNQUOTE DURING THE STORAGE
REPORT PUBLIC SAFETY CRISIS
WHICH IS HAPPENING DURING THE
HELP RIGHT THAT JUST WANTED TO
BE EXTREMELY MIND ON
CIRCUMSPECT ABOUT THE LONG TERM
TO SEND THE CONSEQUENCES OF
WEAKENING THE PUBLIC SUNSHINE
LAWS. AND THEREFORE ASKING THE
LEGISLATURE THE PUBLIC IN THE
PRESS TO EXAMINE THE FOLLOWING
SIX QUESTIONS REGARDING A CA
TWENTY FIVE. ONE WHY SHOULDN'T
BELONG TO THE PUBLIC'S RIGHT.
RIGHT AUTOMATICALLY SUNSET
EVERY SIXTY DAYS WITH THE
REQUIREMENT OF PRE
AUTHORIZATION RATHER THAN
WAITING UNTIL THE
ADMINISTRATION OR THE
LEGISLATURE TO ROUND IT
DECLAING IT AND TO THE
EMERGENCY. TO WHY SHOULD THE
PROVISIONS FOR REMOTE
LEGISLATOR PARTICIPATION THE
LIMITED STRICTLY TO THOSE
LEGISLATORS ARE DIRECTLY
AFFECTED BY THE MARCH IT. THREE
WHY SHOULDN'T THE LEGISLATION
THAT PASSED WITHOUT THE
PUBLIC'S RIGHT TO PLACE TO BE
IMITED TO ONLY THOSE POLICY
AND BUDGET ISSUES THAT PERTAIN
TO THE OPERATION OF THE STATE
DURING THE EMERGENCE BUT- FOR.
WHY SHOULD THE LAWS THAT ARE
IMPLEMENTED DURING AN
EMERGENCY. AUTOMATICALLY SUNSET
AND REQUIRE RE AUTHORIZATION
ONCE EMERGENCY IS OVER AND THE
PUBLIC'S RIGHT YOU'RE FULLY
REINSTATED. FIVE WHY SHOULDN'T
LEGISLATORS WHO PARTICIPATE
REMOTELY HE RECORDED THE
REQUIRED TO CONDUCT THEIR
OFFICIAL DUTIES IN A PUBLICLY
VIEWABLE MATTER TO ALL
COUNTRIES. THE SPECIAL
INTERESTS AND LOBBYISTS ARE NOT
SITTING IN THE ROOM WITH THEM
WHILE THEY VOTE. SIX WHY
SHOULDN'T THE LEGISLATURE
RATHER THAN THE PUBLIC. THE
LEGAL BURDEN OF PROVING THAT
ANY ADOPTED RULES FOR
NECESSARY. IMPLEMENTED IN A
MANNER THAT MINIMIZE THE LOSS
OF THE PUBLIC'S RIGHT. I RAISE
pTHE SIX QUESTIONS BECAUSE AS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN. EIGHT TWENTY
FIVE PROVIDES NEAR BREATHTAKING
LATITUDE TO ANY FUTURE
LEGISLATOR LEGISLATURE TO
ANSWER THESE QUESTIONS ANYWAY
IT CHOOSES TO. AND THEY DO SO
NOT BY PASSING A BILL BY SIMPLY
MAKING A WILL. NO INCLUSION OF
IRISH BODY LEGISLATE OPEN
GOVERNMENT ISSUES USING THE
HIPPOCRATIC OF. PROMISE OF
FIRST DO NO HARM. WITH
WEATHERBLINK AC TWENTY FIVE
DOES NOT USE A SCALPEL TO
ACHIEVE IT SOUNDS RATHER IT PUT
THE MEAT AXE IN THE HANDS OF.
LEGISLATURE'S POTENTIALLY
DISMEMBER THE PUBLIC'S CURRENT
OPEN GOVERNMENT BY. THE PUBLIC
OPEN GOVERNMENT RIGHTS. SO I
APPLAUD THE AUTHOR FOR THE
AMENDMENTS THAT HE HAD OFFERED
I HAVE THE HIGHEST RESPECT FOR
THE AUTHORED BACK TO HAVE THE
DISTINCT PROBLEMS OF SERVING-
WITH HIS FATHER REMEMBER
REMEMBER THOSE TIMES WITH GREAT
FONDNESS BUT I AM CONCERNED
THAT. IF I UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
BODY WILL HAVE BUT ONE POLICY
HEARING. THAT A THIRTY DAY
INCREDIBLE WAS WAIVED. THAT
WERE LITERALLY SAYING A NUMBER
MINUTES BEFORE THE HEARING. AND
AS I READ A THE AMENDMENTS I
HAVE TO ECHO- MISTER DEMERITS
CONCERNS THAT THEY IN FACT HAVE
SUFFICIENT AMBIGUITY THAT THEY
MAY NOT ADDRESS THE ISSUES THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED IN THIS
HEARING. SO WITH THAT I URGE
THE MEMBERS EITHER VOTE NO FOR
YOUR BRING IT BACK FOR SECOND
HEARING WHERE OPEN GOVERNMENT
PARTIES HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE OR
AND THE AUTHORS. TO MAKE SURE
THESE ISSUES AND QUESTIONS ARE
DRESSED IN A MANNER THAT ARE
PROTECTIVE OF THE PUBLIC'S
WHITE. TAKE THAT AS YOUR
CLOTHES THANK YOU CENTER
BLAKESLEE. AT THIS TIME. WE'RE
GONNA TURN TWO OPPONENTS IN THE
ROOM. WHO WISH TO TESTIFY AND
FIGHT YOU FORWARD. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS KATHERINE BRANDON BURKE
AND I'M ALSO THE VICE PRESIDENT
OF IDA BUT I'M SPEAKING FROM A
PERSONAL PERSPECTIVE HERE. I-THINK WHAT ALL THE MEMBERS NEED
TO REALLY CONSIDER WHEN
ADDRESSING THIS BILL. IS THERE
ARE MANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO. THEY COME HERE. TO THIS
BUILDING TO VOICE THEIR
CONCERNS WE SEE THEM ALL THE
TIME AS LOBBYIST WE SAVE YOU
SEE THEM IN THE HOUSE AND LIKE
US. YEAH THE ORANGE SHIRT HERE
THE YELLOW SHIRT SO HERE YOU
KNOW THEY THEY DO COME AND THEY
WANT TO BE HEARD. IF THE
LEGISLATURE IS NOT HERE IN THIS
BUILDING. WHERE THEY GOING TO
GO TO VOICE OUR CONCERNS ON
CERTAIN ISSUES. I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT WHEN YOU
CONSIDER THIS THAT YOU TAKE
EVERYONE INTO ACCOUNT. THAT YOU
KNOW WHAT. FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LIKELY STATED
WHAT MR TOMARI STATED. I
COMPLETELY AGREE WE REALLY NEED
TO LOOK AT HOW THIS BODY. WANTS
TO TAKE PUBLIC EMPLOYEES. IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT WITHTHAT- AS
DRAFTED I DO OPPOSE THANK YOU
VERY GOOD KATHERINE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MISTER CANNON
WELCOME THANK YOU. YEAH MY
NAME'S DAN MCKINNON-
CONSTITUENT OF CAN COOLEY IS
AND I AM I CAME TODAY TO VOICE
MY OPPOSITION TO THIS AMENDMENT
TO THE CONSTITUTION I'M
KINDERGARTEN TEACHER FOR TWELVE
YEARS. AND MAYBE A PERSPECTIVE
THAT I CAN BRING- SPENDING ALL
MY DAYS WITH FIVE AND SIX YEAR
OLD AT. THE WAY WE COME TO
RESOLVE CONFLICT AND MOVE
FORWARD HEALTH BILLY IS- IN
PERSON. IT INVOLVES I CONTACT
IT INVOLVES HUMAN CONNECTION.
AND WE'RE WE'RE DEALING WITH
HOW ARE WE GOING TO TEACH
KINDERGARTEN IN THE FALL AND I
KNOW THAT SIMPLY CANNOT BE DONE
OVER ZOOM. I KNOW THAT IT
CANNOT BE DONE WITHOUT TOUCH
WITHOUT SEEING FACIAL
EXPRESSIONS. AND I'M NOT SURE
HOW WE CAN MOVE FORWARD WITH
THE GOVERNMENT WHERE WE CAN
LOOK EACH OTHER IN THE EYE.
WHERE WE CAN HAVE THE
CONFIDENCE THAT DECISIONS WERE
MADE. BY HUMANS IN CONTACT WITH
EACH OTHER AND SO I'M ASKING
ARE WE REALLY ARE WE REALLY AND
SO MUCH FEAR. THEY WERE GONNA
FORGO THE FUTURE OF OUR
CHILDREN THE DIRECTION OF THIS
NATION AND YES I DO THINK THAT
SOMETHING LIKE THIS AMENDMENT
COULD PROFOUNDLY AFFECT. HOW
DECISIONS ARE MADE I REALLY
CALL INTO QUESTION THAT IT'S
EVEN BEING MADE AT THIS TIME.
RIGHT NOW IF YOU WANT THE
COMPETENCE OF THE PUBLIC IN A
DECISION LIKE THIS. THEN WAIT
UNTIL THE ACCESS IS NOT BEEN
LIMITED TO WERE NOT SOCIAL
DISTANCING. I STAND IN
OPPOSITION VERY GOOD THANK YOU
MUCH FOR CANADA. HE SAID FROM
WELCOME. I GOT MY NAME RIGHT
HEADS FROM THAT'S RIGHT I AM
MARRIED TO THE KINDERGARTEN
TEACHER WHO JUST SPOKE AND JUST
AS A PLUG ON HIS BEHALF- I WILL
SAY I RESPECT WHAT HE DOES ON
ANY GIVEN DAY FAR MORE THAN
WHAT ANY OF YOU DO FOR WHATEVER
THAT'S WORTH BECAUSE THE FUTURE
REALLY IS. IN THE CHILDREN. SO
I CAME UP HERE NOT KNOWING WHAT
I WOULD SAY OTHER THAN I AM
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSED TO THIS.
HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF A DEVICE
HERE THAT'S NOT REALLY. MY
PREFERRED- WAY OF BEING IN THE
WORLD THIS COMPUTER- I HAVE
FOUR CHILDREN I'M A GOAT FARMER.
SO I MIGHT USE THIS AS A BIT OF
A CRUTCH. BUT I'M GONNA TALK
FOR A MOMENT JUST OFF THE FLY
BECAUSE AS I'VE BEEN SITTING
HERE AND LISTENING TO THIS
AMAZING TESTIMONY BY THIS
GENTLEMAN HERE WHOSE NAME I
DIDN'T. CATCH AND THE FELLOW
WHO PHONED IN- WHAT IS COMING
TO MY MIND IS THAT DUE TO THIS
PANDEMIC IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
YOU THE LEGISLATURE HAS GOTTEN
A TASTE. OF WHAT WE
CONSTITUENTS USUALLY DEAL WITH
FROM THE STANDPOINT THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS SHUT YOU OUT OF
THE PROCESS. AND THAT'S WHAT
THE PUBLIC TYPICALLY FEELS FROM
THIS LEGISLATURE AND SO THIS
RUNAWAY TRAIN THAT IS THESE
EXECUTIVE ORDERS THAT IS WHAT
FORTY EXECUTIVE ORDERS THAT
CHANGE TWO HUNDRED LAWS IS A
LITTLE BIT OF A FLAVOR OF WHAT
WE- THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
EXPERIENCE HERE IN THIS
BUILDING FROM YOU YOU WHO ARE
ELECTED OFFICIALS YOU ARE WHO
ARE SUPPOSED TO REPRESENT US
YOU OR WHO ARE SUPPOSED TO HEAR
OUR VOICES. AND WE'RE BEING
SHOT OUT AND NOW YOU WANT TO
TAKE THIS TRAIN TO THE NEXT
LEVEL. YOU WANT TO MAKE THESE
CHANGES IN SECRET IN THE DARK.
AND WE'RE SAYING WAIT THIS IS
WHAT YOU'VE DONE TO US ALL THIS
TIME WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR THESE
LAWS. AND SO NOW YOU HAVE A
TASTE OF IT SO INSTEAD OF
REINING IN THIS GOVERNOR WHO'S
RUN A MUCK YOU WANT TO SADDLE
UP TO THE TO THE LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY. AND I WOULD SAY
YOU KNOW IN THE SPIRIT OF WHAT
MY HUSBAND JUST SAID. NO THANK
YOU RIGHT LIKE. I MEAN I'M AT A
LOSS THE THAT THE LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY THAT THAT THIS
KIND OF AMENDMENT WOULD BRING
ABOUT AND I'M NOT EVEN. A
GOVERNMENT PERSON I MEAN I WAS
GONNA READ SOMETHING FROM. MY
FRIEND SETH ABOUT HOW WHEN DID
THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC
PARTY. BECOME THE PARTY THAT
HAS TO CONTROL EVERY PART OF
LIFE AND I KNOW THIS IS
SUPPOSED TO BE BI PARTISAN. BUT
TO ME IT'S JUST MORE OF THE SIX.
AND REALIZE YOU TO SPEAK TO THE
SUBSTANCE. IN THIS SENSE IT'S A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT THAT
IF IT GOES FORWARD ACTUALLY
GOES BEFORE THE VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA. SO WE DO NOT
ACTUALLY DICTATE THE OUTCOME IF
IT IS PRESENTED TO THEM AS A
QUESTION- CAN I'M AGO FARMER.
YOU KNOW THAT IS I DON'T WANT
TO BE STANDING HERE. WHICH WHEN
YOU STRIP PEOPLE OF THEIR BASIC
CIVIL CONSTITUTIONAL AND HUMAN
RIGHTS CAN YOU KNOW WHAT THE
SERENITY WORE OFF. I TWELVE
KIDS AT MY HOUSE YESTERDAY
BECAUSE SUDDENLY WORLD HOME
SCHOOLING FOR EVER. THERE'S NO
END TO THIS AND THEN YOU WANT
TO MAKE LAWS IN SECRET BECAUSE
WHATEVER ELSE STRIKES YOUR
FANCY BE IT A WILDFIRE YET
ANOTHER PANDEMIC. YOU'RE JUST
GOING TO MAKE LAWS I DON'T HAVE
THE EXPERIENCE THAT THIS GUY
HOUSE I CAN TELL YOU HOW TO
MILK A GOAT. VERY GOOD I
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO DEFEND MYSELF
IN A BASIC WAY. AND YOU WANT ME
TO SPEAK TO THE SUBSTANCE WELL
I'M SORRY I'M ABOUT TO DELIVER
SOME GOLD BABIESTHIS WEEKEND
THERE IS MY SUBSTANCE BUT I
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO FIGHT SO HARD
I SHOULDN'T HAVE TO COME DOWN
HERE AND SPEND. THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON PARKING TRACK MEET
WITH GOD BLESS YOU DEVON MATHIS
AND CUNNINGHAM I JUST SPOKE ON
BEHALF OF YOUR NINETEEN EIGHTY
TWO IN THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE
I MEAN HOW HARD TO THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA AFTER WORK THEY
DON'T EVEN KNOW YOUR HERE.
BECAUSE YOU TRY TO SLAM THROUGH
THE WORK SO THERE'S MY
SUBSTANCE I'M SORRY I'M NOT A
CONSTITUTIONAL LAWYER BUT I
STUDIED RIGHT ALONG WITH MY
EIGHTH GRADER THIS YEAR AND I
UNDERSTAND THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
I UNDERSTAND THE SECOND
AMENDMENT. I UNDERSTAND THE
FOURTEENTH AMENDMENT AND THE
FOURTH BECAUSE MY EIGHTH GRADER
BROUGHT ME UP TO SPEED ON WHAT
I'M SEEING HERE IN CALIFORNIA
ISN'T REPRESENTATIVE OF THAT
AND THAT'S MY TRUTH AND ALL
STICK TO IT YOU SHOULD ALL BE
ASHAMED OF YOURSELVES THAT'S
REALLY MY FEELING SHUTTING
PEOPLE OUT OF GOVERNMENT. NO
THANK YOU I'M AGAINST THIS.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE TWENTY SIR
CALLERS IN THE QUEUE. AND SO I
INVITE PEOPLE TO. MODERATOR IF
YOU OPEN UP THAT LINE AND
INVITE PEOPLE TO PRESENT THEIR
NAME AND THEIR POSITION. AND
WE'RE GOING TO PUBLIC COMMENT
THEN YES. OKAY YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL
BEGIN WITH LINE FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES I
HAD YOUR MIND OPEN HI MY NAME
IS DARLENE AL KISA I LIVE IN
ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA AND I
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE THIS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU FOR
CALLING WE WILL THAT A LINE
NECK BUT A LINE. FORTY SEVEN.
I'M FORTY SEVEN GO AHEAD.
HONORING WE WOKE UP THE NEXT
LINEUP TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS
IS KEVIN BAKER FROM HER CONSOLE
LIBERTIES UNION OF CALIFORNIA
WE DO NOT HAVE A POSITION ON
THE BILL AT THIS TIME- BUT WE
ARE WATCHING WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS. THIS IS A SOCIAL
EXPERIMENT WITH DEMOCRACY WHICH
ISN'T NECESSARILY OBJECTIONABLE
IN OF ITSELF BUT IT IS RISKY
AND WE THINK IT MIGHT BE
PRUDENT. TO STUDY THIS ISSUE
FURTHER AND- OBSERVE THE
EXPERIENCE OF OTHER STATES
BEFORE CENTER BRUSHING
CERTAINLY IN TWO THIRTY TWO
MEDIC DEPARTURE FROM OUR
TRADITION SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH ON THE ALTAR AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS- TO- TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS IS A PROCESS
THAT. DOESN'T HEART FROM OUR-
IMPORTANT VALUES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU MISTER BAKER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
CALLER. I'D LIKE TO BE A LINE.
FIFTEEN NAME POSITION. THANK
YOU FOR CALLING. I HAD MY LOW
CAME YES YOUR OPEN HELLO OKAY
HI YES I'M CALLING TO ASK YOU
TO VOTE NO ON THIS I'M- AND
THIS AMENDMENT. THE
LEGISLATURE'S WORK FOR AND WHAT
DID TO REPREENT THE PUBLIC YOU
WERE AT ELECT TO HOLE UP HOLD
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION. YOU'RE
NOT ABLE TO REPRESENT THE
PUBLIC WILL BE ELECTED YOU IF
WE DO NOT KNOW THE LAWS PASSED
IN IN HE QUIT. THIS IS A- THIS
IS AN AMERICAN. PROPOSED LAWS
SHOULD BE MADE PUBLIC THANK YOU
ARE YOU ABLE TO LET STATEMENT
OPPOSITION RAM. I'M NOT
FINISHED FINISHED WON'T TAKE
LONG. WELL WE ARE. ABOUT TWO
DOZEN OTHER FOLKS ANOTHER QUICK
I'LL BE REALLY QUICK I PROMISE
I PUNCHED THE PROPOSAL LAWS
SHOULD BE MADE PUBLIC THE
PUBLIC SHOULD BE ABLE TO LET
THEIR LEGISLATURE KNOW HOW THEY
FEEL ABOUT PROPOSED LAWS THE
LEGISLATURE TO REMAIN
TRANSPARENT EVERY. REPRESENT
THEIR CONSTITUENTS AND NOT HAVE
LASIK SECRET PLEASE REMEMBER
THE CONSTITUTION BEGINS WITH WE
THE PEOPLE NOT WE THE
GOVERNMENT I HOMES ONLY YOU TO
PLEASE VOTE NO ON THIS.
AMENDMENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. NEXT CALL. ON A LINE
THAT PART YES LINE TWO. HI MY
NAME I MELISSA MARQUEZ I AM
FROM SALINAS CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE I JUST FOUND OUT THAT
THIS WAS GOING ON TWENTY
MINUTES BEFORE IN THAT IS NOT
OKAY YOU CANNOT BE PASSING LAWS
IN THE DARK WITHOUT THE PEOPLE
YOU WORK FOR US IT'S NOT THE
OTHER WAY AROUND. THANK YOU
MELISSA. NEXT CALLER AT ABOUT A
LINE OUTLINED EIGHTEEN. HELLO
CLEARLY YES YES MA'AM HI HI MY
NAME IS BIRTH DEL RIO I AM VERY
PROTECTIVE WHICH IS GREAT THAT
I EXPECT I DEMAND FOR THE
APPROVAL OF THIS LAW YOU COULD
DO ANYTHING IN THE DARK- THERE
HAVE TO BE TRANSPARENCY AND I'M
GONNA SAY THIS PUBLICLY IF I
CAN'T SEE YOUR FACE TO FACE IF
I CAN'T GO TO THE CAPITAL I
DON'T TRUST ME. AND YOU WERE
INSTITUTED BY US YOU REPRESENT.
US AND IT IT IF YOU DON'T SEE
THAT THE NOT ABOUT HUNDRED TOLD
ME THAT. THE THAT'S A
CONSTITUTIONAL. THANK YOU MADAM
THAT IS ON. NEXT CALLER PLEASE
ACTIVE LINE. ENTER THREE. MY
NAME IS TWENTY AKRON AND CHAT I
UP THAT. THANK YOU THE SECOND.
THIS CALL NINE THIRTY OR- BUT
LINE THIRTY FOUR. HI THANK YOU
MY NAME IS TAMMY BECAUSE NICK
AND I'M CALLING FROM SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY- I AM VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE EFFORT TO
REMOVE TRANSPARENCY IN THAT
PROCESS THE PROCESS IS THE
IMPORTANT PART OF IT ALL THE
WAY TO CAN BE HEARD I STRONGLY
OPPOSE EIGHTEEN TWENTY FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT CALLER. NEXT WE'RE GONNA
LINE FORTY. HELLO MY NAME IS
ANASTASIA DOWN FROM SANTA
BARBARA I AM CALLING HIS
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE IT ON
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT THAT
YOU ARE PRESENTING THAT PEOPLE
NEED TO BE A PART OF THE
PROCESS AND THEY CUT THEM OUT
EMERGENCY ARE NOT. WE ARE THE
PEOPLE NOT THE GOVERNMENT THANK
YOU THANK YOU MA'AM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THAT LINE TWENTY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RANDALL
GRECO I'M A RETIRED TO
HONORABLY RETIRED CALIFORNIA
PEACE OFFICER OF THE REASON
THAT I'M CALLING IS THAT- I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS PROPOSED A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WANTS TO PRESENT IT TO THE
PUBLIC TO VOTE ON BUT I THINK
THE PUBLIC HAS ALREADY TOLD THE
LEGISLATURE WHAT THEY WANT IN
THE CONSTITUTION. THERE'S NO
REASON TO HAVE LEGISLATION DONE
IN THE DARK I UNDERSTAND THE
NEED FOR CONTINUITY OF
GOVERNMENT THAT'S IMPORTANT BUT
THE- THERE IS A NEED TO ALTER
THE CONSTITUTION. TO DO THAT
AND- FOR THAT REASON HI ECHO.
THE MAJORITY OF THE STATEMENTS
IN OPPOSITION THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE- PREVIOUSLY AND ASKS THAT
THE- OF THE LEGISLATURE OF.
VOTE NO ON THIS A PROPOSED A
LEGISLATURE THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR CALLING TODAY OFFICER
GRECO- NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ACTED LINE FORTY FOUR. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS MARK HE MET
THE OWNER OF SMITH POLICY GROUP
AND A BOARD MEMBER OF AYE GA
I'M CALLING TO EXPRESS MY
CONCERNS IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE IN SOLIDARITY WITH THE
MEMBERS OF THE I. G. BOARD THE
IRONY OF CALLING OVER THE PHONE
TO DO THIS IS NOT A SKI-
HOWEVER I WOULD LIKE TO DRAW A
DISTINCTION BETWEEN PROVIDING
REMOTE TESTIMONY VERSUS HAVING
A PUBLICLY ACCESSIBLE
LEGISLATURE AND PUBLICLY
ACCESSIBLE MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU MISTER SMITH.
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. NEXT
DEADLINE FIFTEEN. HEY I
UPLOADED TO THE CAB DISABLED
FROM PACIFIC CALIFORNIA WE
DON'T **** YOURSELF SOME FOR IT
AND I OPPOSE THIS ORDER THE ALL
THE WAY WE THE PEOPLE ARE NOT
GONNA TAKE THAT THE LORD ALMOST
THAT THE END OF THE WAR. THANK
YOU KNOW MORE YOU GUYS SO BUT
THE ADS FOR IT IF THE FATHER
GOVERNOR WAIT WE HAVE PEOPLE
FEEL LIKE IT'S A THANK OUR
RIGHT NOW THANK YOU FOR NOTED
YOUR OPPOSITION THANK YOU FOR
CALLING NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ACTUAL THAT'LL FIFTY FOUR. HI
MY NAME IS KATHY BUT- I'M IN
THAT THE LOS ANGELES A- AND I'M
OUT. A PAUL. THAT ANY UP THERE
AND- THINK THAT THIS IS A
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS- SO I OPPOSE
A CA. TWENTY FIVE AND I AM
LETTING ALL OF THE NEWS
OUTLETS. KNOW ABOUT THIS AND
THE REST OF THE UNITED STATES
KNOW ABOUT THIS THIS IS.
DISAPPOINTING THIS IS
UNDEMOCRATIC. AND IT IS A-
EIGHT CAN LEAD TO. YELL AT
PASSING LAWS WITHOUT LETTING
THE PEOPLE KNOW I WANT TO
REMIND YOU GUYS. YOU REPRESENT
THE PEOPLE. HOW CAN YOU
REPRESENT THE PEOPLE IF YOU
DON'T LET THEM IN. TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. THANK YOU
HAS PROBABLY. NEXT CALL ACCESS
LINE FIFTY SEVEN YES LIFT THAT
THEIR TRUMP CAPITAL JOHNNY
OPPOSES THIS DAY FIVE AND I
THINK OF THAT YOU KNOW YOU NEED
A TO GO TO PROTECT ALL PEOPLE
OF THIS AND NOT THE NUMBER ONE
RIGHT NOW PEOPLE ARE BUYING
GUNS TO PROTECT THEMSELVES
GRAHAM BUT YOU FEEL PHONE HERE
IN NOVEMBER WE ARE. MOLD YOUR
FONG OKAY THANK. YOU SIR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR CALL THANK.
NEXT CALL. NEXT DEADLINE FIFTY
FIVE. HELLO MY NAME FOUR FIVE
THAT IN CALLING FROM LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND I FINALLY
OPPOSED. THANK YOU MA'AM THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE THAT. LINE THIRTY EIGHT.
HI MY NAME IS THE ARRIVAL AND-
YES MA'AM. I MY NAME IS A LABEL
MEN AND I'M CALLING IN
OPPOSITION TRANSCEND BARBARA
COUNTY I'D ALSO LIKE TO ADD TO
THAT THE QUESTIONS THAT LIKE WE
PUT FORTH- AND WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THAT THE DRAFT IN ANY
FOLLOW UP MEETING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR CALLING. NEXT
CALLER. CALLER ID LINE SIXTY
FOUR. AT NINE SIXTY FOUR. HELLO
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON. YOUR NAME
IF I. SIR MY NAME IS TONY ONE
I'M FROM THE SENATE BILL I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL AND
THIS THE NOT TENTH PERSON AND
THE CLEAR AGAINST THE
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE'S WILL WELL
SO WE DO NOT WANT THAT LATER.
TO TOP THE NORTH RESULT PEOPLE
MONITORING. BECAUSE WE DO NOT
TRUST THE POLITICIANS BADLY
DEMOCRATS. PLEASE ACTED AT THE
COMPLETE YOUR SET OKAY SO A
BICYCLE BUT YOU'RE SET DO NOT
TRY TO ALTHOUGH EIGHT WITHOUT
OUR STATE THANK YOU IR THANK
YOU FOR CALL OUT. YES THANK GOD
SCHOLAR. NEXT HEADLINE EIGHTEEN.
WELL HELLO THANK YOU FOR
CALLING. JERRY. YES YES MA'AM
YES INDEED. OKAY BASICALLY I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT WE THE
PEOPLE ARE NOT GOING TO PUT UP
WITH A LONG TRAIN OF ABUSES AND
A LONG TRAIN OF USURPATION.
THANK THE PEOPLE WILL NOT
CONVICTED HERE ANY. WE THE
PEOPLE WILL STAND UNITED AND WE
SEE PASSED THE DIVISION THAT'S
BEING PROPAGATED AND PUSH YOUR
SOCIAL MEDIA ANSWER NEWS
OUTLET. WE'RE GONNA STAND
UNITED A WE'RE GOING TO GET
THROUGH THIS- AND WE'RE NOT
GOING TO LET ANY OPPRESSORS GET
TO US. AND WE'RE GONNA NOT LET
ANY TYRANT. KEEP US FROM MOVING
ARE CALLED WE ARE UPSET WE ARE
VERY UPSET YOU KNOW THAT WERE
IN OPPOSITION. HOW MANY PEOPLE
NEED TO SPEAK FOR SHOW ABOUT
THE CAPITAL TAKE TIME FOR THE
DAY YOU KNOW WHAT WE ARE
CONTRIBUTORS TO THE US ECONOMY
WE WORK FOR A LIVING. SO YOUR
JOB IS TO REPRESENT US AND
WE'RE TELLING YOU. THAT WE
STRONGLY OPPOSES. IN THANK YOU
FOR CALLING CALLER PLEASE. WE
DEADLINE. SIXTY FIVE. HI MY
NAME IS JESSICA CABRERA
IDEOLOGY I AM A CONSTITUENT OF
LOS ANGELES I COMPLETELY
OPPOSED WELL I BELIEVE THAT I
THANK YOU AND HAVE EVERY
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO BE
INVOLVED IN HERE ALL THE LAWS
BECAUSE OUR CRAFTING THAT THE
SHOULD BE DONE IN SECRECY IN U.
S. AS ARE APPOINTED OFFICIALS
SHOULD HONOR THAT. AS WE THE
PEOPLE DO ELECT YOU TO BE A
REPRESENTATIVE THANK YOU MADAM.
YOU TO OPPOSE. PLEASE EXCEPT.
THIRTY YEAH MY NAME IS MIKE
MATTINGLY. WHAT CONSTITUTES AN
EMERGENCY WHO'S GOING TO CALL
IT THE FIRE POWER OUTAGE. ADRIN
INVASION GOVERNOR GOT OUR HUMAN
RIGHTS WHATEVER THIS IS NOT HOW
WE DO IT I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
ABOUT THIS CALL TO LIKE FIFTEEN
MINUTES BEFORE IT HAPPENED THIS
IS WHAT YOU GET WHEN YOU HAVE A
DARK GOVERNMENT RUNNING AND ALL
OF THOSE LEGISLATORS UP THERE-
JUST TAKING THAT MONEY. WE NEED
TO REMEMBER WHERE THE PEOPLE.
WE DON'T WANT THIS CRAP COMING
DOWN OUR THROAT AND IF WE IF WE
HAD NO RIGHT. PROTESTERS
GRUESOME SAID SO WE DID BECAUSE
OF THE CONSTITUTION GUARANTEES
OUR RIGHT TO PROTEST THIS IS
THE KIND OF CRAP THAT GETS IN
THE WAY OF THAT THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER MATTINGLY. NEXT CALL.
OUR NEXT CALL THAT A LINE SIXTY
SIX. HI GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
MEMBERS THIS IS MICHAEL MILLER
FIVE A REDLANDS SACRAMENTO
FULLY SUPPORTING THE BILL I'M
SORRY I DIDN'T GET IN EARLIER
THAT WILL SUPPORT UP IS TRYING
TO DO I THANK THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
MILLER. WE HAVE THE SEVERAL
DOZEN CALLS YET. NAME IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE CONTINUE
MADAME MODERATOR. WELL THAT A
LINE NINETEEN. HI MY NAME IS
KAREN LESTER AND I AND BERMAN
THANK YOU COUNTY AND IDEA
NIGHTLY HELLO THE- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CALL YOU FOR HOLDING. OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. I WILL GO TO
LINE FORTY FIVE. OKAY BEARD YES
YES SIR BY NOW I'M A
CONSTITUENT OF THE MONTEREY
COUNTY AND ALL I WANT TO SAY IS
MEETINGS THAT HAPPENED IN THE
DARK OR WOULD ALLOW PEOPLE LIKE
JEFFREY AT TO GET AWAY WITH
RATE IN ZABUL. EIGHTEEN MONTHS
BACK TO BACK IF REDUCE THE
THIRTEEN MONTH AND A CITY MOST
WE DO NOT OPERATE IN THE DARK
WE NEED PEOPLE TO HEAR
EVERYTHING THAT YOU'RE NOT WITH
THAT GET THAT THING YOU FOR
YOUR TIME SIR. PLEASE HI AND
THEN I WE DID HAVE ONE MORE
SPEAKER NECKLACE. IT ON. THANK
YOU SIR COOLEY MEMBERS PEOPLE
START ON REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA COMMON BECAUSE
HOUSING BECAUSE OF A FORMAL
POSITION ON A FEW TIMES FIVE
THAT STRUCK MY BOARDS TICKET SO
TO SPEAK HOWEVER WE DO HAVE
SOME CONCERNS OF THOSE THINGS
HERE THAT WE SHARED WITH THE
AUTHOR I DO WANT TO GO ALSO AT
SESSIONS WITH MOUNT OFFICE
BETWEEN SHARED. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WHICH WE NOT HAD A CHANCE TO
REVIEW THE LEGAL WAY TO SOME OF
THE MORE SERIOUS CONCERN
GENERALLY SPEAKING THOUGH WE
WOULD JUST ONE OUTSIDE OF THE
REMOTE SHOOTING PRESENT THAT
CAN ALL SCHOOLS TO. PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT WE WANT SURE THE
REMOTE PARTS STATION WON'T BE
OFFERED VERY EXCEPTIONAL WHEN
ABSOLUTE NEEDED WE ALSO SINCE
THE CAN ABOUT PART VOTING WE
CAN WE CAN BOTH DELIVER
GOVERNMENT AND TEN HOW THE BILL
A LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE TO
ENGAGE THIS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR MORE MISTER HEIDER. MY
NAME THEREFORE ONE NIGHT. I'M
CALLING TO. OPPOSE AC EIGHT
TWENTY FIVE AS WELL AS IS THE
FIVE. ANNIE MAC AMENDMENT OF
CONSTITUTE TUITION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. EIGHT FIVE AND A
THREE EIGHTY ARE ALL THE SAME
NATURE THAT PEOPLE ARE NOT
TREATING EQUALLY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. ANY FURTHER
COLLARS AND NINE EIGHT THANK
YOU. YEAH WELL THAT'LL NINE
SEVENTY SIX. HI GABRIELLE
INGRAM AS SACRAMENTO COUNTY- I
STRONGLY OPPOSE IN AN EMERGENCY
PUBLIC COMMENT IS NEEDED MORE
THAN EVER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR THE CALL. A HUNDRED. WE
WANT. HELLO YES I HAD. JEFF
MANAGERIAL WE ARE OPPOSED TO
TWO EIGHTY IN HEIGHT THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
DEADLINE EIGHT EIGHT FOUR.
EIGHTY EIGHT TWENTY FIVE AYE
OPPOSED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU FOR CALLING NEXT
CALLER. THERE'S NO ONE OUT
THANK YOU AT THE TIME OKAY.
THEY ARE HAVING. PROBLEMS THEY
ARE WE- HOLDEN. THE PRODUCT.
WHAT ABOUT. THEY ARE WAITING.
WE'LL PROCEED WITH THE HEARING.
YOU HAVE ONE MORE LEFT ON THANK
YOU ONE MORE YES. I LINE FORTY
SEVEN. HELLO MY NAME IS JOE AND
I'M CALLING ASIAN AFRICAN.
AMERICAN BALD EAGLE RIGHT WE
ARE FATHER AND THE MEMBERS OF
GAS EIGHT THE EIGHT TWENTY FIVE
ALSO ALL WE GET A DAY. EIGHT
EIGHT FIVE EIGHT EIGHT FIVE
COULD BE DISCRIMINATION. AND
POLITICAL DISCRIMINATION. ANY
THEM THE LAW DOCTOR WAVEFIELD
YOU ARE. NO RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MATT A MODERATOR
LITTLE LIGHT SEVENTY LOOK AT
ONLINE SEVENTY EIGHT. HELLO.
YES I OPPOSE. EIGHTY EIGHTY
EIGHT TWENTY FIVE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I. THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER. JUST A FEW
MARKETING UP HERE ONE MOMENT.
YEAH. BUT A LINE FIFTEEN I GOT
IT. HELLO SIR HEADLINE FIFTY
NINE. YES HI MY NAME IS JACKIE
PROBLEM CALLING FROM SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY- AND I AM
ENGAGEMENT OPPOSITION TO THIS
AMENDMENT TO THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION I'D ALSO LIKE TO
NOTE THAT IT APPEARS THAT THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- ARE
BUSY ON THEIR CELL PHONES WHILE
PEOPLE ARE- CALLING IN- TO
EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION AND
THAT'S- CONCERNING AS WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SIR. MADAME MODERATOR LINE YEAH
LINE NINETY THREE. HI HELLO MY
NAME. ONLY HI FOR ME YES MA'AM.
OKAY WELL MY NAME HE ADDED
QUALITY WILL STRONGLY OPPOSE TO
BOTH A SAY A TWENTY FIVE AND
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT FIVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU MA'AM. MADAME
MODERATOR ACCESS LINE ONE OUT
TO HI I'M IS IT ME YES SENATOR
OUT RIGHT. LOOKING PHÃN
CALLING IN FROM SANTA CLARA
COUNTY WHERE IN OPPOSITION. TO
EIGHTY EIGHT TWENTY FIVE AS
WELL AS EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE- ANY
AMENDMENT TO THE CONSTITUTION
SHOULD BE HEARD BY THE PEOPLE
AND- GOVERNMENT SHOULD WORK FOR
THE PEOPLE I THINK HAVE BEEN
VERY UP HER. DOWN THE PRE
BERMAN IS GETTING FURTHER AND
FURTHER AWAY FROM THE PUBLIC
AND I HOPE THAT THIS MATTER
THEY GOT. BACK THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT CALLER.
THERE'S NO ONE LIKE YOU ALL
RIGHT WE CLOSE THAT LINE. NOW
RIGHT ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS. MR MATHIS. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. YOU KNOW WHEN
I FIRST HEARD ABOUT THIS. EIGHT
OUT A LOT OF CONCERNS. AND
FRANKLY I STILL DO. BUT WHEN I
SIT HERE. AND I DIGEST THIS I
THINK ABOUT THIS AND I THINK
ABOUT THE MASSIVE EXECUTIVE
POWER. THAT OUR GOVERNOR HAS
DURING A STATE OF EMERGENCY.
AND HOW WOMEN DID THE POWER. OF
THE ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE
BODIES BECOME DURING THOSE
TIMES WHICH WE DON'T GET TO
CALL THE GOVERNOR GETS TO CALL.
SO WE WHEN YOU START LOOKING AT
THIS HOW DO WE BALANCE THIS
POWER ROUTE. HOW DO WE ENSURE
THAT. THOSE OF US THAT THAT ARE
ELECTED AND I THINK ABOUT THE
HOW CRAZY IT IS. AMBER'S IN L.
A. AS AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE
REPRESENT. JUST UNDER HALF A
MILLION PEOPLE THAT THAT'S MORE
THAN THE GOVERNOR OF MISSOURI.
SO THIS MORE THAN A GOVERNOR OF
A LOT OF THE STATES THAT THAT
ARE AROUND US AND- TO THINK
ABOUT THAT AWESOME
RESPONSIBILITY. AND TO THINK
ABOUT WHAT HAS HAPPENED OVER
THE LAST COUPLE OF MONTHS. OVER
THE ABILITY OF A GOVERNOR TO
JUST ONE WITH A PEN. AND CHANGE
THAT TO GO RIGHT PAST THE
LEGISLATIVE BODY IN AND FRANKLY
DO WHATEVER THE HELL HE WANTS.
AND THEN I LOOK AT THIS AND GO.
IF FOR SOME UNGODLY REASON THIS
HAPPENS AGAIN. I DON'T WANT TO
BE STUCK ON THE SIDELINES.
WATCHING ON THE NEWS. THE
GOVERNOR TO SIGN ANOTHER ORDER
WELL WHAT SENATE WALL THERE
GONNA COME OUT WITH DETAILS
LATER IN THE WEEK. IT IS MY
HOPE. EXPRESSLY TO MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER MULLIN HOOCH HEADING
THIS UP. THIS GIVES US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REAL IN THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT
TO REAL IN THE BUREAUCRATS THAT
THE FRANKLY TEND IGNORE EVERY
THING WE TRY TO GET THEM TO DO-
BECAUSE THEY TEND TO INTERPRET
THINGS HOW THEY WANT. IN
RESTORE SOME OF THAT POWER BACK
TO THE LEGISLATORS I DO HAVE
GRAVE CONCERNS. ABOUT THE
TRANSPARENCY SIDE OF IT.
BECAUSE WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
TALK TO OUR PUBLIC AND WE
SHOULD BE DOING THAT IN FOR THE
PUBLIC. IF WE'RE NOT RECALLS
MAY ONE THOUSAND. ONE SPEAK TO
THAT SO I THINK WITH THAT. I
I'M GONNA SUPPORT THIS TODAY
MOVING FORWARD. NOT SURE HOW
MANY VOTE ON IT. ON THE FLOOR
THE ASPECT THAT THIS GOAL SUCH
POTENTIALLY ON THE BALLOT WHERE
PEOPLE CAN HAVE MORE TIME TO
READ IT TO UNDERSTAND IT. TO
SEE HOW THIS WILL PLAY OUT TO
TAKE THE POWER AWAY FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE BODY AND GIVE THE
POWER TO THE PEOPLE TO VOTE ON
IT. I THINK IS IMPORTANT. IS
THAT A MOTION ON THE BILL OF
PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED THE
AMENDMENT CENTER BEFORE SIDE.
YEAH ALL ALL MAKE THAT MOTION.
BUT I'D LIKE TO HEAR WHAT THE
AUTHOR HAS TO SAY ON THIS I'VE
NOTICED SHE'S BEEN TAKING
COPIOUS NOTES- I THINK WE ALL
HAVE CONCERNS OKAY MISTER
MULLIN WILL USE PLEASE I THINK
WE WANT TO SEE THIS MOVIE. OUR
AT. ALL UP. MISTER CHAIR I GET
A DRESS ANOTHER A NUMBER OF
ISSUES- AS I GEAR UP FOR MY
CLOTHES IF YOU'D LIKE TO-
CUNNINGHAM. YEAH I BET THANK
YOU MISTER THANK YOU MISTER
MULLIN I MAY RAISE SOME ISSUES
YOU MIGHT WANT TO DRESS AS
WELL- YEAH I STRUGGLED WITH
THIS BEFORE DECIDING TO COME ON
BOARD AS A CO AUTHOR. FOR A LOT
OF THE SAME REASONS AS THE
PEOPLE ON THE PHONE AND
CHAMBERS TODAY HAVE
ARTICULATED- I THINK
TRANSPARENCY IS IMPORTANT I
THINK IT'S VITAL. I DON'T THINK
WE HAVE ENOUGH OF IT TO BE
HONEST WITH YOU. I HAVE
CONCERNS SURROUNDING THAT- BUT
ULTIMATELY- YOU KNOW OUR- OUR
STATE GOVERNMENT SET UP UNDER
THE SEPARATION OF POWERS
STRUCTURE- THAN IN MANY WAYS
MIRRORS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WE HAVE THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
WITH THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE BRANCH- UNDER
THE EMERGENCY SERVICES ACT THE
GOVERNOR OF OUR STATE HAS- THE
UNILATERAL POWER. DECLARE AN
EMERGENCY- WHICH SHE
APPROPRIATELY DEAD DUE TO COVER
NINETEEN. IN THE MIDDLE OF
MARCH- BUT FROM MARCH
SEVENTEENTH TWO TO. TEN MAY
THIRD. OF THIS YEAR- AS
LEGISLATORS AS REPRESENTATIVE
OF NEARLY HALF MILLION PEOPLE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE
WERE LARGELY SHUT OUT OF THE
PROCESS OF GOVERNING THIS IS.
CRITICISM OF ANY PARTICULAR
BORDERS BUT I WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT THERE BEEN FORTY PLUS. THE
CHANGE- WORKERS COMP LIABILITY
LAWS THE CHANGE VOTING RULES
THEY CHANGE ALL SORTS OF
THINGS- WITHOUT THE LEGISLATIVE
DELIVER PROCESS IN THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR TRANSPARENCY IN
INPUT FROM THE PUBLIC THAT'S A
PROBLEM. THAT'S A PROBLEM. A
IT'S A BIG PROBLEM THIS. WEEK
WE NEED TO FIND THE BALANCE SO
WE HAVE THE PEOPLE'S
REPRESENTATIVES WHO SPEAK FOR
OUR CONSTITUENTS AND ARE ARE
RECEPTIVE TO THEM AND HEAR WHAT
THEY HAVE TO SAY AND TELL US.
AND THEN CARRIED OUT FORWARD
INTO INTO THE GOVERNING BODY-
AND ENACT THAT THROUGH A-
CONSTITUTIONAL DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS. AND WE'VE GOT TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT DURING
EMERGENCIES I DON'T KNOW WHAT
KIND OF. NEW EMERGENCIES WILL
COME UP IN THE FUTURE AS PEOPLE
POINTED OUT NOBODY EXPECTED
THIS PANDEMIC TO COME UP- BUT
I. I DID NOT ENJOY HAVING
CONSTITUENTS JUST LIKE ALL THIS
EXPRESSING THEIR GRAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE DIRECTION OF STATE
GOVERNMENT. ON AND HAVING SOME
VERY UNPRECEDENTED DRACONIAN
THINGS BEING IMPOSED UPON THEM.
AND A AND ASKED TO MAKE
TREMENDOUS SACRIFICE FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH- YOU HAVE WHICH WAS
APPROPRIATE AT AT THE TIME FOR
A TIME BUT I DIDN'T LIKE THE
FACT THAT MY ONLY ABILITY TO
INFLUENCE. STATE GOVERNMENT IN
CALIFORNIA WAS. CALLING AND
EMAILING THE GOVERNOR YEAH. I
DON'T THINK THAT'S GOOD. THAT'S
WHY I THINK THIS BILL WOULD
RESTORE SOME OF THE DEMOCRATIC
POWER TO CREATE- A LITTLE BIT
BETTER BALLOTS I A SO THAT'S
WHY I ULTIMATELY DECIDED TO
COME ON BOARD- TO SUPPORT IT
HI. WITH WITH DUE REGARD TO THE
TRANSPARENCY ISSUES AND I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE
WORKED ON ALSO IT SHOULD BE
MENTIONED FOR EVERYBODY THAT
CALLED IN OPPOSITION PEOPLE
THAT SPOKE WE ARE VOTING TO PUT
THIS ON THE BALLOT FOR THE
VOTERS TO VOTE FOR. THERE'S
NOTHING MORE DEMOCRATIC THAN
THAT THE VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA
WILL DECIDE IN NOVEMBER WHETHER
THEY WANT THIS CHANGE OR NOT.
WE'RE GIVING THEM THE OPTION. I
THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT STATE
FOR THE RECORD VERY CLEARLY- I
DID HAVE ONE TECHNICAL QUESTION
ON THE PROXY VOTING ASPECT- I
SEE A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN REMOTE
VOTING. AND PROXY VOTING PROXY
VOTING DOES TO ME RAISE SOME
CONSTITUTIONAL. CONCERNS THAT
ARE NOT RAISED. IT WITH THE
SAME LEVEL WITH RESPECTIVE
REMOTE VOTING IN A I WAS
HOPEFUL YOU COULD ADDRESS THAT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN AND YOUR
CLOTHES THANK YOU. MR GRAYSON.
YES THANK YOU MISTER. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND JUST TO
CLARIFY THE VOTE THAT WE TAE
TODAY IS TO- VOTE- ON THE ACA
TWENTY FIVE AS AMENDED TO MOVE
IT TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR FOR
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
THAT IS CORRECT AND AS AMENDED
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR. THIS WORKS WELL
WHEN WE HAVE A MOTION IS THERE
A SECOND. AND THE LIKE THE
FORTY. OKAY YOU JUST LOOK AT
THE POINT THAT. YEAH I DID THAT
THAT OKAY WAS FROM A VEIN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU MISTER MALONE FOR- FOR
INTRODUCING THIS WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH MEMBERS
AND ALSO STAKEHOLDERS. ON ON
DEVELOPING THIS THIS THIS COULD
BE THE MOST CONSEQUENTIAL BILL
THAT WE PASS- THE SESSION OR
EVEN IN IN OUR TIME THE
LEGISLATURE SIMPLY BECAUSE THE
CONTINUITY OF GOVERNMENT IS TOO
IMPORTANT- TO PASS- UP AT THIS
TIME. AND IT AND IT'S
INTERESTING TO HEAR THE
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
A PARTICULARLY FROM- I GA-
WHICH- I APPRECIATE THE
FEEDBACK THAT THEY PROVIDED IN
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE ACA AND
THE CONCERNS THAT THEY HAVE BUT
AS OUT. OF LAWMAKERS HAS WE
HAVE ADJUSTED TO RUNNING IN THE
ASSEMBLY IN IN THE PANDEMIC OR
EVEN AS A PARENT WITH TWO
CHILDREN. DISTANCE LEARNING WE
HAVE ALL NEEDED TO ADAPT AND
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO GET THROUGH
THE STATE OF EMERGENCY. AND DO
IT AS ELEGANTLY AS POSSIBLE
WITH THE LEVEL OF. QUALITY AND
CERTAINLY IN IN GOVERNMENT.
LEVEL TRANSPARENCY AND
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT THAT IS
NECESSARY AND SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'VE DONE HAVE
ACTUALLY INCREASED- HERE IN THE
CAPITAL ENGAGEMENT. WHICH HAS
BEEN NOTED FOR EXAMPLE THE
ABILITY TO PETE FOR PEOPLE THAT
WHETHER THEY CAN TAKE THE DAY
OFF FROM WORK OR CARING FOR A
LOVED ONE- AND CAN SPEND MONEY
TO TRAVEL TO SACRAMENTO AND
TAKE THAT AND TO GET TO SACK.
SO THAT NO MATTER WHO YOU.
EIGHT IN THIS PROCEEDING AND-
AND THAT'S A PRETTY AMAZING
THING IT'S A IT'S A GREAT
THING- BECAUSE OF THE HIGH COST
OF ACTUALLY GETTING TO
SACRAMENTO THAT'S TOO MANY
PEOPLE HAVE TO EXPERIENCE OR
DECIDE THAT THEIR PRESENCE
ISN'T SOMETHING THAT THEY CAN
AFFORD TO DO- OF COURSE THEY'VE
ALWAYS BEEN ABLE TO WRITE
LETTERS AND WE WANT TO CONTINUE
TO DO THAT AND DO THAT BY. ALSO
NOTED IS THE CONCERN ABOUT WHEN
THIS WHATEVER OCCUR BECAUSE WE
CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO AND THE
WAY THAT WE HAVE TRADITIONALLY
CONDUCTED OUR WORK. WITH THIS
ACTUALLY REALLY IS A- WORST
CASE SCENARIO BUT ONLY UNDER
CERTAIN COMMIT CONDITIONS AND-
WITH RULES THAT HAVE BEEN
AGREED TO- BY THE TWO HOUSES SO.
THERE IS A LOT OF. IF THE EAST
ASKED BY VOTERS RULES MUST BE
AGREED TO BY THE ASSEMBLY AND
THE SENATE. FOR HOW TO- CONVENE
IN THAT STATE OF EMERGENCY AND
SO THERE IS A LOT MORE WORK TO
BE DONE TO YOUR HOW WE ENSURE.
ACCESS AND TRANSPARENCY- IN
THAT STATE OF EMERGENCY MEETING
AND SO AGAIN I WANT TO THINK
THAT THE MEMBER THE OP.
EVERYONE HAS BEEN THAT CRITICAL
FEEDBACK WE NEED TO GET THIS
RIGHT. WE NEED TO HAVE
GOVERNMENT WORK AND TOO OFTEN-
I BELIEVE THAT THOSE WHO WANT
TO END THE OPPORTUNITY HAVE
COME IN OF GOVERNMENT ARE
ACTUALLY INTERESTED IN MAKING
SURE THAT GOVERNMENT DOES NOT
WERE DISCORD. SO DISTRAUGHT AND
TO UNDERMINE CONFIDENCE IN THE
ABILITY FOR GOVERNMENTS TO DO
THE IMPORTANT WORK THAT WE DO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR HAVING.
SO WHAT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND TO THE AUTHOR AGAIN I KNOW
NOW- MY STUDIES YEAH WE ARE.
CALLER. PROBABLY REALLY YOU
WERE YEAH I THINK PEOPLE ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT TO KNOW
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW. SOME OF
THE KEY WORDS THAT ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW NOT ONLY TO
CALIFORNIA BUT ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES OR WORDS LIKE
PUBLIC PER PATIENT TRANSPARENCY
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE
INTEGRITY IN OUR GOVERNMENT
DâN AS WE LOOK AT THE CIVIL ON
REST. SOME OF THE ANGER WE'RE
HEARING IT BECAUSE HE- CAN AND
OF CELL BLOCK FROM GOVERNMENT
AND THAT'S NOT NECESSARY ONLY
IN SACRAMENTO IT CAN BE AT
THEIR LOCAL FOR MEN. TIMES A
PUBLIC. THE AMOUNT OF KHAT I
KNOW WHEN I FOR AIR FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WHERE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS CAN SPEAK FOR THREE
MINUTES ON A TOPIC IN SOME SOME
EVEN LONG. ON NOT POSTED ITEM
IT WAS A SHOCK TO COME UP HERE
AND FIND OUT THAT THERE WAS TWO
WITNESSES WHO COULD SPEAK AND
THEN YOU COULD EITHER STATE OP
CENTER SUPPORT. THOUGH I KNOW.
YOU KNOW THE PUBLIC DOESN'T
ALWAYS IS IN THEIR ARE FOR TO
THESE THEY LOOK THE IDEA THAT
IF THEY CHOOSE. A SO I THINK
THAT I WILL STILL. IN THIS
FORWARD BUT- THE CONCERN THAT I
HEARD ABOUT WILL WE MAKE UP A
REASON TO HAVE AN EMERGENCY OR
WHAT WOULD BE THE CRITERIA FOR
A FUTURE EMERGENCY I THINK THAT
THERE SO THAT BELIEVE WE
SHOULDN'T HAVE EVEN CALL THE
CALL THE NINETEEN MARGINS
ENDEMIC. IN THAT'S UP FOR. AND
BUT- I STARTED ON ANOTHER ISSUE
TODAY RULES WAS THAT WE ARE ALL
ON ELECTED BY DISTRICT ALMOST A
HALF A MILLION VOTERS VOTE AND
WE REPRESENT THEM AND I TAKE
THAT SERIOUSLY. AND WITH THAT I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
VOTERS KNOW WHAT WE'RE GOING NO
WHERE WERE AT. IT WE SHOULD BE
HERE AND WE CAN BE. SO THAT
MEANS I WANT TO CLEAR TO THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE WATCHING THIS
THAT THIS WILL NOW GO TO THE
FLOOR OF THE STATE ASSEMBLY.
AND IT PASSED IT WILL GO TO
BALLOT. THERE IS MORE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE PUBLIC TO
WEIGH. FOR IT READ. AND TO BE
CLEAR BECAUSE SEVERAL OF THE
JURORS MENTION WE'D BE UP IN A
SENSE CREATE RULES HAVE SELECT
BY. AND THEN. NOT WHAT YOU
PROPOSED HERE BUT I DO IN THE
PUBLIC LAST BUT NOT LEAST I
THINK WE HAVE SEEN SOME.
ADDITIONAL UP OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THE PUBLIC TO BE INVOLVED WITH
THE CALL WHEN CALLS THAT WE'VE
HAD ALSO WITH ZOOM MEETINGS AND
SO FORTH I KNOW NOW EVEN THOUGH
I'M HERE. CAN PARTICIPATE IN
ZOOM CALL THE MY EX OF EVENTS
GOING ON. IN THE DISTRICT WHERE
I REALLY NEVER. TO NEEDED
BEFORE. SO I THOUGHT WE'DTAKE
THE BEST FROM THIS CRISIS BUT
WHAT THE FOCUS ALWAYS ON WE
SERVE THE PUBLIC THANK YOU. I
HAVE A MOTION IS THERE A SECOND.
CENTER BY MS CARILLO. I WANT TO
SPEAK TO THIS AND- THIS ISN'T A
FINISHER I THINK IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO NOTE AS HAS BEEN
EXPRESSED. THIS IS A PROPOSED
CONSCIOUS AMENDMENTS WHAT
ACTUALLY HAS TO GO BEFORE. THE
WE THE PEOPLE TO WEIGH AND
EVALUATE IT. I THINK IT IS A
DEEPLY PROBLEMATIC IN OUR
SISTER GOVERNMENT TO HAVE A
CIRCUMSTANCE ARISE. THAT SIGNED
LINES AND RENDERS AN EFFECTIVE
THE LEGISLATURE. AT A TIME OF
CRISIS. THE OUR SYSTEM OF
GOVERNMENT DOES NOT WORK WELL
WHEN ONE ANYONE BRANCH OF THE
GOVERNMENT. HAS THE UPPER HAND
IN THE OTHER BRANCHES ARE
IMPOTENT. SO. I ACTUALLY FEEL
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
QUESTION. HOW DO WE MAKE MAJOR
EFFECT IN TIMES OF CRISIS SO
OUR JOB OF BEING A- CHECK AND
BALANCE WITHOUR DEMOCRATIC
SYSTEM GOVERNOR CAN BE UPHELD.
THAT'S WHAT THIS PRESENTS AS A
QUESTION. I WANT TO MAKE AN
OBSERVATION ABOUT THE
TIMELINESS ACTUALLY OF A
QUESTION LIKE THIS. YOU KNOW
THINGS APPEAR ON THE BALLOT ALL
THE TIMES THE LEGISLATURE MAY
PUT THINGS ON THE BALLOT THEY
MAY ARRIVE HERE BY. THE
NATIONAL. IT IS NOT TYPICALLY
THE CASE THAT MATTERS ARRIVE ON
THE STATEWIDE BALLOT AT A
MOMENT. WHEN THE PUBLIC IS TO
REALLY THINK ABOUT HOW THEY
FEEL ABOUT THE ISSUE. IN THIS
SENSE WE HAVE THREE PHAM LI
LARGE FACTORS. THAT
CALIFORNIANS EVERYONE OF THEM
ARE WELL ACQUAINTED WITH THE
EVOLUTION OF TECHNOLOGY AS IT
AFFECTS ALL OF OUR BUSINESS IS
DONE THIS IS A REALITY IN
EVERYONE'S LIVES AND THE THREAT
BOUND UP IN A CA TWENTY FIVE
BUT FOR THE TECHNOLOGIES AND
EMERGE WE WOULD NOT BE IN THIS
QUOTE. WE WOULD NOT HAVE TO PAY.
THE YOU COULD REMOTELY WITH
ACCOUNTABILITY I THANK YOU FOR
AGREEING TO THE AMENDMENT THIS
MORNING. SECONDARILY WE HAVE
THIS THIS PANDEMIC WHICH AGAIN
PEOPLE ARE IN THE MIDST OF
THEIR CUENTA WITH TO UNDERSTAND
HOW DESTRUCTIVE IT IS BEEN. SO
THE QUESTION BECOMES IF YOU
BELIEVE IN ACCOUNTABLE
GOVERNMENT IF YOU BELIEVE IN A
LEGISLATURE THAT STANDS UP FOR
WE THE PEOPLE. IF THEY ARE
PREVENTED FROM DOING THEIR JOB
BY SOME HEALTH CRISIS HOW THEY
FEEL ABOUT THAT. AND FRANKLY I
FEEL THIS MOMENT. OF. BEING A
GAS TO WHAT HAPPENED TO MISTER
FLOYD. AND THE PUBLIC REACTION
AND PARTICIPATION HAS ENSUED
FROM THAT. WHICH IS THE PUBLIC
EXPRESSING ITS INHERENT RIGHT
IN OUR DEMOCRACY TO BRING ITS
VOICE TO BEAR. I ACTUALLY FEEL
THAT TO IT IT'LL BE A PART OF
THE CONSIDERATION OF THIS THIS
FALL. TECHNOLOGY OVERHEAD AND
THE RIGHT OF THE PEOPLE TO BE
HURT. I THINK THESE THREE
ELEMENTS FRAME HOW PEOPLE LOOK
AT THIS DECIDE HOW THEY FEEL-
YEARS AGO TWENTY TEN PROP
NINETEEN WAS ON THE BALLOT THAT
WAS A MEDICAL. MARIJUANA AND
ISSUE. AND MIGHT. I WENT ALONG
WITH MY COLLEAGUES A POODLE
MATTER ON THE BALLOT DO A
TAXATION MARIJUANA. AND I
THOUGHT WHAT BETTER TIME TO ASK
MY VOTERS TO THINK ABOUT
MARIJUANA TAXATION WHEN THERE'S
A HUGE DEBATE HAVE BEEN ON
MARIJUANA LEGALIZATION. AND I
FOUND IN RANCHO CORDOVA PEOPLE
HAD NO TROUBLE DECIDING HOW
THEY FELT ABOUT NINETEEN BUT
ALSO OUR LOCAL MEASURE. AND I
FEEL VERY MUCH THE SAME WAY
THIS IS A MOMENT IN TIME WHEN
BECAUSE OF THE EMERGENCE OF
TECHNOLOGY THE COVE IT. AND THE
CURRENT- TIME OF PROTEST PEOPLE
WILL FIGURE OUT QUICKLY HOW
THEY FEEL ABOUT THIS AND THEY
WILL BE ABLE TO THINK ABOUT THE
PRO AND CON OF SUPPORTING THE
STATION EXERCISE OF ITS
CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY. SO ANY
FURTHER COMMENTS BY ANY MEMBER
MISTER MOORE WE GO DO YOU TO
RESPOND AND CLOSE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND THANK YOU
MEMBER AND I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THAT WHICH
IS ON DISPLAY IN PARTICULAR IS
CUNNINGHAM SPEAKING TO- THE
IMPORTANCE OF REPRESENTATIVE
GOVERNMENT- IN THESE
EXTRAORDINARY TIMES THE
IMPORTANCE OF CHECKS. AND
BALANCES IN TERMS OF MISTER
CUNNINGHAM QUESTION ON- REMOTE
VOTING PROVISIONS. ACTUALLY
VOTING- OF VERSUS TECHNOLOGICAL
MEANS MANY OF THOSE DIFFICULT
ISSUES WOULD BE WORKED OUT IN A
RESOLUTION. THAT THE VOTERS ARE
SPECIALLY AUTHORIZING US TO PUT
FORWARD TWO THIRDS VOTE IN BOTH
HOUSES THE VOTERS WOULD BE
AUTHORIZING US. TO EXPLORE A
REMOTE VOTING CAPABILITY
PERSONALLY I. BELIEVE REMOTE
VOTING USING TECHNOLOGICAL
MEANS WITH FULL PUBLIC INPUT
AND PARTICIPATION UTILIZING THE
ONLINE TOOLS THAT WE HAVE MAY
BE PREFERABLE TO PROXY VOTING
THAT'S JUST A PERSONAL
PREFERENCE BUT WE'RE GOING TO
BE HAVING THOSE DISCUSSION
ROBUST DISCUSSIONS IN- BOTH
HOUSES WHAT. COMES TIME TO
ADOPT THE RESOLUTION WHERE SOME
OF THESE REALLY TRICKY ISSUES
CAN BE WORKED THROUGH I WANT TO
THANK THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
FOR CALLING. IT IS SUB OPTIMAL
THE PHONE OPERATION YOU HAVE
TECHNOLOGICAL ISSUES THERE THIS
IS IN PERFECT BUT THE PUBLIC IS
HAVING THEIR VOICE HEARD TODAY
ON THIS VERY ISSUE AND
ULTIMATELY THEY'RE GOING TO
DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT TO
AUTHORIZE. US TO MOVE FORWARD
AND I DO HOPE SOME OF THE- AND
OPPONENTS HAVE THE- MOST RECENT
VERSION WITH. A VERSION OF THIS
ACA WHICH STRENGTHENS- THE
PUBLIC INPUT AND TRANSPARENCY.
TIONS IN ALIGNMENT WITH PROP
FIFTY FOUR SO- MANY OF THOSE
ISSUES THAT ARE OUTSTANDING-
WILL BE DEALT WITH IN THE
RESOLUTION WHEN THAT COMES TO
BEAR BUT- JUST IN TERMS OF
PUBLIC INPUT WHAT I'M
ENVISIONING IS THAT WE USE-
ONLINE TOOLS HEARINGS FLOOR
SESSION. ALL OF THOSE
DELIBERATIONS ONLINE VISIBLE TO
THE PUBLIC NOT IN THE DARK
ONLINE FOR EVERYBODY TO SEE AND
RECORDED AND CAPTURED AN
ARCHIVE- PURSUANT TO A PROP
FIFTY FOUR- AND IT MAY UNDER
THESE EXTREME CIRCUMSTANCES
WHERE THIS WOULD APPLY AND KEEP
IN MIND WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF
PANDEMIC NOW BUT WE'RE HAVING A
HEARING IN THIS BUILDING. WE
ARE MOVING FORWARD WITH
BUSINESS OF THE PEOPLE THESE
ARE THE MOST EXTREME
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE WE HAVE A
SAFETY CONCERN ABOUT PHYSICALLY
BEING IN THIS BUILDING HAVING
THIS IS A FAIL SAFE A SO WE CAN
KEEP THE BUSINESS OF THE PEOPLE
LIVING FOR. AND HAVE SENT BACK
THIS IS. OUR PROCESS. SO IN
TERMS OF- BLAKESLEE OR HAVE A
GREAT RESPECT FOR HERE IS A
NUMBER OF ISSUES THAT GO BEYOND
THE SCOPE OF THIS A CA VALID
ISSUES TO BE SURE- BUT IN TERMS
OF THIS EASY HEY WE ARE ALL ON
A EXTREMELY CONDENSED TIMELINE
TO GET THIS THROUGH BOTH OF OUR
HOUSES AND GET IT TO THE
VOTERS. OF CALIFORNIA- BUT I
WELCOME HIS INPUT AND HIS
EXPERTISE AND HIS WORK AROUND-
DEMOCRACY IN TRANSPARENCY
ISSUES WHEN WE WORK ON- THAT
RESOLUTION SHOULD THE VOTERS
AUTHORIZED INTAKE CONCERNS
TROUNCED IN SETTING PROVISIONS
AND SO FORTH THOSE ARE ISSUES
THAT WE CAN DEAL WITH BUT WE
GET TO THE REST. PROP BEST THE-
OF THE A FISH UP. OF THE LOBBY
COMMUNITY TO THIS I'M CANDIDLY
A BIT PUZZLED BY THAT. IN THAT
YOU KNOW I HAVE I HAVE GREAT
RESPECT FOR THE WORK OF THE LOT
THIS IN THIS BUILDING WE RELY
ON THEIR EXPERTISE. ON A
REGULAR BASIS AND- WILL
CONTINUE TO ROCK RELY ON THEIR
EXPERTISE AND I'M CONFIDENT
THAT UNDER HESE EXTREME
CIRCUMSTANCES IF WE'RE
PHYSICALLY NOT IN THIS BUILDING
THE LOBBYING COMMUNITY KNOWS
HOW TO GET A HOLD OF US AND
HAVE THEIR VOICE HEARD. THAT
HAPPENS ALL THE TIME. WHEN
WE'RE NOT IN THIS BUILDING IN
TERMS OF THE PUBLIC THIS ENTIRE
EFFORT IS BEING DONE WITH
PUBLIC INPUT. OUT FRANKLY WELL
WE'VE BEEN HOME DURING RECESS
I'VE NEVER HEARDMORE FROM THE
PUBLIC. BECAUSE OF ALL THE
ISSUES WITH ADD AND THE
ECONOMIC- THE DEVASTATION
THAT'S BEING FELT ACROSS THE
STATE- SO THOSE ARE THROUGH
TECHNOLOGICAL MEANS- WE ARE
HEARING FROM THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC AND THAT WILL CONTINUE.
TO BE PARAMOUNT. SO LIMIT LET
ME JUST SAY- IN CLOSING OUT AYE
IT'S BEEN A LONG HEARING LONGER
THAN I THOUGHT. LET ME JUST SAY
IN CLOSING MISTER CHAIR THAT
CALIFORNIA. IS THE HOME OF
TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATION WE
SHOULD BE LEADING ON THE ISSUE
OF UTILIZING TECHNOLOGY TO
ENHANCE PUBLIC ACCESS AND
TRANSPARENCY. AND BUILD A
MODERN DIGITAL DEMOCRACY WE
SHOULD BE DOING THAT IN
CALIFORNIA. UNDER THE MOST
NARROW OF CIRCUMSTANCES WE
SHOULD BE DOING THE DIGITAL
DEMOCRACY ANYWAY BUT THE
APPLICATION OF IT IN A REMOTE
VOTING SETTING IT'S GOING TO BE
UNDER THE MOST EXTREME. OF RARE
CIRCUMSTANCES I WANT TO THE
SIZE THAT I AM TOTALLY
COMMITTED TO ENSURING THAT ANY
CONSTITUTIONAL CHANGES. WHEN
SOLUTION ON. ANY TOTAL HARMONY
WITH. FOR AN OPERATE TOTALLY IN
THE SUBSTANCE AND SPIRIT OF
FIFTY FOUR WHICH IS
TRANSPARENCY AND OPEN
GOVERNMENT. PROP FIFTY FOUR
WITH OVER 65% OF THE VOTE
THAT'S ALMOST A SUPERMAJORITY
OF OUR VOTERS THEY WANT OPEN
GOVERNMENT THEY WANT
TRANSPARENCY WE NEED TO BE
OPERATING IN THAT SPIRIT- IF WE
MAKE ANY CONSTITUTIONAL
CHANGES- PURSUANT TO A VOTE OF
THE PEOPLE WITH TRANSPARENCY.
PUBLIC ACCESS AT THE FOREFRONT.
A HOUSE RIGHT NOW IS UTILIZING
PROXY VOTING. AND THAT'S AN
EXPERIMENT I'M SURE WILL BE
ANALYZED BUT LET ME EMPHASIZE
WE ARE SUBMITTING THIS TO THE
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA AWAY AND
TOTALLY COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH MR BLAKESLEE. MR MONGER
OTHER GOOD GOVERNMENT GROUPS
THAT WERE SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSITION FEAR BEFORE TO MAKE
SURE CALIFORNIA GETS THIS
CONSTITUTIONAL MODERNIZATION.
AND MAKES GOVERNMENT MORE
TRANSPARENT NOT LAST WENT ON AN
UNEXPECTED EMERGENCIES STRIKE
CALIFORNIA. AND FINALLY MISTER
CHAIR LET ME JUST SAY
CALIFORNIA OF ALL PLACES. THE
END OF EARTHQUAKES FLOODS FIRES
AND NOW PANDEMICS. AND THE MOST
POPULOUS STATE IN AMERICA
GRAPPLING WITH THIS QUESTION OF
DEMOCRACY AND PARTICIPATION
MUST HAVE A CONTINUITY OF
GOVERNMENT PROVISION. IN OUR
CONSTITUTION AND I ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. OKAY IS IT BEEN MOVED
AND SECONDED THANK YOU FOR THE
CLOTHES- MATTER SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM TO AND
THIS IS A CA. TWENTY FIVE AS
AMENDED. THAT IS THE MATTER
BEFORE. WE. MAN SO PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. A MOTION ON A CA
TWENTY FIVE BE ADOPTED AS
AMENDED COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I.
CARILLO. CARILLO AYE FLORA.
LARA AYE GRAYSON MASON I
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS OR MATHIS
ARE QUIRK SILVA QUIRK SILVA I
RAMOS PROMISED I RIVAS. RIVAS
IRON WORKS LEVINE LEVINE AYE
THE MOTION PASSES. FORGET THAT
MOTION IS PASSED WE GO NOW TO
ITEM THREE- IS OUR MOTION ITEM
THREE. AND IT'S MOVE BY WHO.
MISS CARRILLO SECOND OF BY MR
RIVAS VERY GOOD. I UNDERSTAND
YOU GUY YOU HAVE SOME CONCERNS
WITH THAT DO YOU WISH TO SPEAK
TO IT OKAY MATTER SURGERY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM
THREE. ITEM THIRTY URGENCY
CLOSE REQUEST FOR SB FOUR
TWENTY THREE COOLEY AYE. COOLEY
AYE CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM NO
CARILLO. CARILLO AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS. MATHIS NOW
QUIRK SILVA. QUIRK SILVA I'M
SORRY SAID I THANK YOU QUIRK
SILVA I RAMOS RAMOS I RIVAS
RIVAS I'D LIVING. LEVINE I. AND
THAT MOTION PASSES SEVEN THREE
THAT MOTION IS PASSED AND THIS
RULES COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.